Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. Tonight we got
part two. If you guys have not seen part
one, you're going to want to go back and
check out the King of the North and the
King of the South. We did that
presentation with Ernest Rosa uh at the
beginning of the week and now he's back
for part two. This might be a three or
fourpart series and so many people were
just inspired, were educated, were
wanting to hear part two. And I can't
wait for this one because it's going to
dispel a lot of the misconceptions about
prophecy. Part two, he really went into
who is the king of the south, who is the
king of the north from the Bible alone,
from geography, from history. And to me,
it was a solid case. But he's going to
make it even more solid tonight. So, I
want to introduce my brother Ernest here
tonight. Thank you so much for coming
back and for giving us more information
because I think it's really important to
understand prophecy in the last days.
And there's so many voices out there,
man. You you just don't know like
different denominations, different time
periods. You know, some people interpret
it this way at one point in time. And
but what you've been saying to me is
straight biblical, straight historical,
and um I'm ready to see more, man. So,
thank you for coming back on.
>> Yeah, it's a pleasure to be back on with
you, my brother. Um, yes, I've gotten a
lot of positive feedback to be honest
with you. One of the main things is that
you stated that people feel like they
have really been able to understand it.
>> Yes.
>> I try to break it down as best as I
could. Um, and that's what I'm hoping to
do here today. Um, today is going to be
kind of a if that last one was a hot
potato, this is the steaming.
>> Even more, huh?
Yeah, because we're going to be tackling
something that I believe that we do need
to discuss. I'm going to give my point
of view again. I'll repeat again. I'm
going to throw the chips on the table,
let it fall where they will, and let
everybody it, analyze it, scrutinize it
to the best of their ability, but it's
with the hope that they will see for
themselves and study for themselves,
search out for themselves, scrutinize it
for themselves.
>> Yes.
>> And see what is true and not. But again,
as we stated before, we have to come
into this with an open mind.
>> Amen.
>> Okay? If I'm wrong, I'm wrong. If I'm
right, I'm right. But I don't even like
to say if I'm right. If the truth is
right, it's going to glide. If the truth
and this is not the truth, it's going to
go fall flat.
>> You know,
>> that's right.
>> Um, so, you know, that's that's just the
way that I look at it.
>> No, that's the way I am, too, man. I I
I'm never afraid to look at any ideas.
You know, when people say, uh, hey, let
me, you know, would it be okay if I
share your idea? Yes, please do. because
I want to know. I want to see all the
opinions because I I believe the truth
will stand. And that's how I got to
where I'm at today. I was raised in, you
know, uh, Baptist churches where they
believed a whole lot of different things
than I believe today. And it was all
because I just I've always been an
open-minded, truth-seeking skeptic. And
I still am. And so I'm still always
looking for truth. And I got a cool
shirt on here today. Be cool. Use your
brain. That's what we want to do. We
want to use our brains.
>> So, I'm going to I'm going to put um Oh,
I'm glad I checked because we don't even
have your slide on here. You need to
share your um
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I did it purposely.
Let me uh You know what? Hold on a
second. Let me put it up.
>> Let me put it up. Hold on.
>> Here we go. Oh, that's not it.
It's this one.
All right. Here we go. Mikey, I
apologize. I kind of thought that I
>> Oh, you need to you got to share it. Oh,
you got Okay, cool. Let's see if it's
there now. Go ahead and
>> All right.
>> All right. Here we are.
>> Are we good on your end?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. All right.
>> You want to say get into it?
>> Yes. But I of course I'm on your
platform. So I would like you to have
you know the privilege of doing such
thing that we can get close to the heart
of um Jesus by way of prayer. So please
we may offer.
>> All right. Lord father in heaven we just
thank you so much for this beautiful day
you've given us and we just ask that you
would uh be with our hearts, be with our
minds and give us eyes to see. Lord you
say spiritual things are spiritually
discerned and none of this is by our own
wisdom. This is only from the guidance
of the Holy Spirit and from your word
alone. And you tell us to study line
upon line, precept upon precept, here a
little, there a little, by the mouth of
two or three witnesses. And I know
personally in my life um I've been
introduced to a lot of ideas that just
came from one or two texts and not
studying uh here and there and and
everywhere in your word. So, we just ask
that you would give us um the desire to
dig for truth like gold, to continue to
dig deep and to uh use our discernment
to know whether this is true, whether
this is in in your word, whether it can
stand up to the test of to the law and
to the testimony. And I just ask that
you'd be with us and our audience, that
you would fill us with your Holy Spirit,
that we would just have a blessed time
here. And I thank you for everyone
that's here tonight when they could be
anywhere else. They choose to be here in
your word and it just makes me feel
happy. And so we just love you Lord.
Thank you for all that you do and ask
you be with us in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. Thank you brother Mikey for that
wonderful prayer. All right. So today we
got it's going to be a tough one for
some not not for all granted. And of
course I had to really debate and how I
was going to present this. I have to
always remember that there's people that
are coming on, especially to your
platform, and I'm I'm one of those that
are new, too, that don't have a backdrop
to prophecy, let alone what we do know,
what we've studied. So, we have to be
considerate of them. I don't want to
lose that audience. So, as as a result,
this is going to be it's going to be a
long one here today again, okay? But it
was it's built with the intention
to try to help those that don't have a
correct knowledge of prophecy or any
knowledge of prophecy to let them in.
Like it's that the Lord is about to open
up another window for them for them to
be able to their heads and say, "Wow,
there's something else to this." And
we're going to do that with another
particular prophecy. not directly
um
this prophecy doesn't it's not directly
affiliated with Daniel chapter 11 but
you're going to see the reason why I
have to tag it and that's because in the
the beloved church that I belong to
there is a a fork in the road to
a belief that
Daniel 11
verse 40 in particular means something.
We'll get to that at the latter end.
>> But for those that are coming for the
first are coming on for the first time
or second time, what we're going to do
first is we're going to recap the basics
to what we talked about the last time we
met. And then I'm going to throw in
another strong gem that I did not
discuss in reference to Daniel chapter
11. And then we're going to springboard
it all the way to the last book of the
Bible, the book of Revelation, where
we're going to talk about another
particular prophecy. And then after
that, what we're gonna do is we're gonna
talk more to the people that believe
in this particular
the people uh we're going to speak to
the audience that are either on the
fence of of a particular belief or that
do believe
that the king of the north rather the
king of the south is another entity than
the one that I believe it to be.
>> We'll get to that at the latter end. So,
we're going to be reading a lot. So, I'm
just letting the audience know we're
going to be reading a lot. And and
folks, you're going to see the reason
why we need to read and we need to be
accurate in what we do believe.
>> We'll get to that and I'll set it up
later on. Okay. Now, let's go with the
disclaimer. The fair use notice,
copyright disclaimer under section 107
of the copyright act of 1976. allowances
made for f for fair use for such
purposes such as criticis and comment,
news reporting, teaching, scholarship,
education and research. So let us
remember that the purpose of these
meetings or this presentation is to
teach is to help educate and you can do
your own research as I have done my own
research. Now
today subject is entitled Daniel Leven's
north and south kings and extra. I'm
just throwing this to be part of the
series and I'm doing this more so for
those that do pertain to the belief or
rather to the church that I belong to
but also for those that may may not and
they still believe it for something that
they've read or something that they come
across.
>> Okay.
>> Now
do understand that we're going to also
section it out in two sections. Okay. So
for for right now, we're going to deal
with section one. Okay? And what section
one is going to deal with is what we
dealt with with the in the in our last
presentation. I'm just going to briefly
recap to get to another golden gem to
understand some of the issues that was
happened with the king in the north.
Okay? And then like I said, we're going
to springboard it um to the New
Testament. Okay? So, as we mentioned
last week, and I've cut a lot of out for
the sake of time, Daniel 7, in Daniel
chapter 7, Daniel is the one that is
actually having a dream. He has a vision
where the Bible makes it very clear that
he that in that vision, he sees four
specific beasts that come up from the
sea. All right? One was a lion which had
eagle's wings. The second was a bear
that lifted up itself on one side, had
three ribs in the mouth of it between
the teeth of it, and then also it was a
foreheaded leopard which had four wings,
one leopard, four heads. And then
finally, a terrible and dreadful beast
which had 10 horns, iron teeth, and it
was it was it was a very ugly-looking
beast. That's something that you don't
want to be married to.
>> Definitely.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Bible says this is what
Daniel writes. He goes, "I saw my vision
by night and four great beasts came up
from the sea, diverse one from another."
So that would mean that those beasts
would not be similar to one another.
They will be different. Diverse means
different. And I am using the King James
version, which I that's just the version
that I do prefer above all. Okay. Now,
we asked a question last time for those
that are here for the first time. What
do beasts represent in Bible prophecy?
But Mikey, what what be what do bees
represent in Bible prophecy? Uh when you
read Daniel, it says that the fourth
beast was the fourth kingdom. So Bible
interprets itself tells us what the
symbol represents. Beast equals kingdom.
>> So I want you to read these next two um
verses for me. All right. I'm going to
put up on the screen. Read those. Read
this verse 17 of Daniel chapter 7.
>> All right. These great beasts which are
four are four kings which shall arise
out from out of the earth.
>> So the four beasts represent what? for
kings.
>> Okay. Now, kings rule what?
>> Kingdoms.
>> Very good. So, the next verse explains
that for us. Go ahead.
>> Thus he said, thus he said the fourth
beast shall be the fourth kingdom upon
earth.
>> Okay. So that would mean that beast
represents kings, kingdoms or political
empires. We covered that the last time.
Yeah.
>> Right. Okay. So these are the four
beasts that Daniel saw in vision. Now
remember these are beasts that come up
one after another. We came to understand
that Babylon was the first one which
eventually handed the scepter over to
the next rising power which was Meo
Persia. Persia become eventually
becoming the greater out of the two
because it was initially a a dual
dynasty and then eventually Persia will
hand the scepter over to Greece. Whereas
Greece later on would hand the scepter
over to the first phase of Rome which
was considered pagan Rome or Imperial
Rome. Okay. But eventually pagan Rome
will hand it scepter over to papal Rome.
When we say paple Rome, this is the
Roman Catholic Church, the papacy.
This was the church that became a ruling
power during the time that we discussed
about the during the time of the dark
ages. But what Daniel chapter 2, Daniel
chapter 7 also informs the reader is
that that papal system will not last
forever because eventually that papal
system will hand his scepter over to the
future king Jesus. And Jesus would never
handle his kingdom over to anyone else.
He would share his kingdom with us.
Okay? But he would never hand it. In
other words, it would never be taken
from him ever again. Amen.
>> Now, chapter 11, we discussed the way
that the setup that Daniel has set it up
or um yeah, the way that it's been set
up. When I say Daniel set up, Gabriel
explained to him certain things. Daniel
11 goes handinhand with Daniel 10 and
Daniel 12. As I mentioned before, Daniel
10 is the prelude. Daniel 11 is the
story line, the chapter itself. And then
the conclusion is found in Jan in Daniel
chapter 12. In Daniel chapter 10, the
angel Gabriel appears to Daniel and says
the following. And behold, in hand
touched me and which set me upon my
knees. And he said unto me, Oh Daniel, a
man greatly beloved, understand the
words that I speak unto thee. Now I am
come to make thee understand what shall
befall
um you know what shall befall thy people
in the latter days. Now I asked a
question before who are Daniel's people
in the last days? Well we came to
understand by two specific verses that I
placed on the screen. We're going to be
dealing with this much more so in our
next um presentation. Okay. But for
right now, as we did the last time, we
came to understand according to
Galatians 3 27 and 29. The Bible says,
the Apostle Paul writes to the
Galatians, "For as many as you have been
baptized unto Christ have put on Christ,
neither there is, sorry, there is
neither Jew nor Greek. There is neither
bond nor free. There is neither male or
female. For ye are all one Christ in in
Christ Jesus. And if you be Christ's
then ye are Abraham's seed and hes
according to the promise." Yeah.
>> If you were to go to Romans, um, Brother
Mikey, can you be kind enough to read
this verse?
>> Yeah. For he is not a Jew, which is one
outwardly outwardly. Neither is that
circumcision which is outward in the
flesh. But he is a Jew which is one
inwardly and circumcision is that of the
heart in the spirit and not in the
letter those or whose praise is not of
men but of God. So Mikey, so what are
you understanding as we discussed in our
last meeting? What are you understanding
from these two verses? What is Paul
trying to tell the people?
>> I'm understanding that God is not a
respector of persons, that he doesn't uh
favor one nationality over another. You
know, I'm thinking about um the rich man
of Lazarus parable was all about that
the rich man wasn't saved by his
bloodline or his wealth. You know, that
that was the belief at the time that
>> your bloodline if you were a Jew, you
were automatically one of God's people
and if you were wealthy, then you were
blessed by God. But we're told that we
are all one in Christ Jesus.
>> Correct? So, we're all in Christ. Now,
again, we're going to talk heavily,
we're going to talk much more on this on
this point in our next meeting, okay?
because it's going to also tie in to the
latter part of Daniel chapter um 11.
Now, in dealing with Daniel 11, now
we're going to go to the story, if you
will. Um in Daniel 11:2, as we covered
before, it stated as follows. Behold,
there shall stand up yet three kings in
Persia, and the fourth shall be far
richer than they all. We came to
understand that the first anchor point
had to deal with Persia. the kingdom of
K P P P P P P P P P P P P P P P P P P P
Persia dealt with was was seen in Daniel
11:2A.
But in 2B, the Bible reveals the next
rising power. I'm going read this again
from the top, and we're going to glide
all the way to the ending of that verse.
It says here, "Behold, there shall stand
up yet three kings in Persia, and the
fourth shall be far richer than they
all, and by his strength, through his
riches, he shall stir up all against the
realm of Grecia." Now all of the details
behind this we discussed it in our last
meeting. So if you're watching and did
not see the first meeting you have to go
to the first meeting to understand who
are these four kings and then the and
specifically the fourth king and then of
course you I will fill in it will fill
in the gaps of what I'm not going to do
here because for the sake of time I need
to glide right through all this. Now you
notice at the bottom Mikey which is the
kingdom that is mentioned there at the
bottom
>> it says Grecia Greece.
>> Okay. So Greece is the next power that
the Bible in Daniel chapter 11 is going
to talk on. Now remember as we did talk
and as we did state before any time that
a new kingdom was going to rise to power
the preceding kingdom that was discussed
about will vanish from the from the
chapter and you will never hear that
about that chapter I mean about that
kingdom ever again. So right now the
topic or the one of f the one to be
focused on will be the kingdom of
Greece. Now in verse three, the Bible
states that there will be a mighty king
that shall stand up and shall rule with
great dominion and do according to his
will. We have to understand and identify
the term stand up. Now we came to
understand and Mikey, what does the word
stand up mean again?
>> Uh means to take kingship.
>> Okay, take kingship. Okay. So that could
mean that within the kingdom, another
king was going to rise to power within
his own kingdom or another rival was
going to rise and take the kingdom from
the their predecessor. Okay? So now this
was referring to the kingdom of Greece.
Okay? Now remember when Daniel is being
told this when he's being explained by
the angel Gabriel, Gabriel has to it is
just it has to be that he sets a map in
his presence. In other words, in vision
he's looking at a map. And why? Because
of the reasons that I'm going to get to
in just a bit. So we do have here the
kingdom of Greece. And we know that
Greece came and attacked or it actually
conquered the the area of Jerusalem. But
I want you to notice still speaking
about the kingdom of Greece in the NIV
version of the Bible. Verse four tells
us a little bit more about the kingdom
of Greece. And it says here after he had
appeared, his empire shall be broken up
and parcled out.
In other words, that's saying to split
out to be split toward the four winds of
heaven. It will split four directions,
if you will. It will not go to his
ascendants. That's talking about King
Alexander the Great. It would not his
kingdom was not going to be over to his
his descendant because that infant child
could not take the kingdom. Remember on
his deathbed it was stated that somebody
asked him,
"Who do you give your kingdom over to?"
And he either said, "To the mightiest or
to the strongest." And at that moment,
that's when you had all his four
generals come. At least in the movie
depicted, not that I recommend it. I
think I mentioned it before, but I'll
repeat it again. There's a movie called
Alexander where you had Angelina Jolie,
Val Kilmer. Um Um I don't know. Did you
ever watch that movie back in the day?
Um Mikey,
>> what movie was it?
>> Um
>> it was called Alexander Frell.
>> I never did.
>> Okay. This was a movie that I watched
back then. I don't recommend anybody, at
least a Christian, not to be watching it
only because of not only the violence,
but also the immorality that it that
that that is revealed there. So I don't
recommend it. But I'm just telling you
that even the movie had it correct. It
had a correct beginning at the beginning
about the conquest, the final conquest
of of Persia to become the number one um
um empire. And then at the end, what I'm
just stating here, it actually reveals
at the end of the movie where the four
generals come in and there's a big fight
there to split the kingdom. Now, who
were these others? As noted before, it
was Cassander Lysmicus Salucas Talamy.
Now, Lysmicus was actually his personal
Alexander's bodyguard, personal
bodyguard before he became one of the
kings. We came to understand that
Cassandra took on the territory of
Macedonia. Lysmicus took on Thrace and
northeast Asia Minor, Salucas, Syria,
and Babylon. And Talamy was Egypt, north
northern Africa.
Then the Bible goes on to tell us
according to Daniel 11:es 4-8,
you can read it in its entirety. I'm not
going to read it in all in its full
entirety, but if you read verses 5-8, it
says here, "But out of the out of a out
of a branch of her roots shall one stand
up in his estate, which shall come with
an army, and shall enter into the
fortress of the king of the north, and
shall deal against them, and shall
prevail, and shall also carry captives
where, Mikey into where?"
>> Egypt.
>> Into Egypt. Okay. and he shall continue
more years than the king of the north.
So obviously there are two opposing
forces that are formulated at least in
this particular verse. Now remember in
Daniel 11:1
the Bible says here and the king of the
south shall move shall be moved with
cola that's another word for anger and
shall come forth and fight with him even
with the king of the north. So there
there are fighting they these become
rivals. So question who are these kings
of the north and kings of the south.
Remember people are going to like bang
their heads. Well who are who is the
Bible referring to? But this is where
we're helping you out within the kingdom
of Grecia where you had the four general
I mean rather the four generals which
actually became the four um um kings
because Greece was split into the I mean
it it it became um it was it was split
four different ways because there was a
massive civil war that took place. You
had Cassander that took on Mesania. And
you can go on. You, as a matter of fact,
what if you read it, Cassander was the
one that actually took was on the way of
taking the body of Alexander right back
to Greece where it was hijacked by Tommy
himself and Tommy took it to Egypt where
Alexander was buried. But till this day,
no one knows his actual grave site.
That's very interesting. Just a little
bit of information that people don't
know. Now,
And speaking of the four generals, what
Daniel 11 does now is focus on the
latter two. The first two is never
discussed again is the is Salucas
Lucas's kingdom and Talmy's kingdom.
Okay. Now what you will find is Salucas
Salucas
his kingdom becomes the Seucids to the
north and the Talmic sorry Talomeics to
the south. What do I mean? You'll see
that just a bit by map. So again, north
and south. Seus to the north, talomeic
to the south. When you look at a map,
remember the only way that Daniel can
understand this is by looking at a map.
And he understood it by looking at a map
in vision. And he saw the Seucid dynasty
and the Talmies to the south and Seus to
the north and the Talmies to the south.
Now
remember that Gabriel said something to
him earlier in order to find a dividing
line to what is north and what is south.
Angel Gabriel told him what shall befall
upon thy people in the latter days. So
again looking at the map you have the
solucid to the north tame to the south.
The dividing line is Jerusalem God's
people. God's people. So
anchor point number one was established.
Now we go to anchor point number two.
From 112B
all the way to 1116A
is talking about the kingdom of Greece.
Okay. Now question Mikey according to
the prophecy in the previous prophecies
will Grecian Empire would the Grecian
Empire last forever?
Hello,
Mikey.
>> No, it will not last forever. Sorry,
this is muted. No.
>> Oh, sorry. Okay. Oh, wait. Hold on. Let
me put this back on. Okay. I just
thought I lost you completely. Okay.
>> So, so it would not last forever. Okay.
So, now we know that of course as as as
we just explained earlier that the
Grecian Empire is going to hand
eventually hand the scepter over to
another rising power. Now in verse 16 of
Daniel 11, remember I gave I gave a
little bit more context the last time we
met for the sake of trying to glide
through this to get to the main point
later on. I need to just, you know, give
the these strong points, make these
strong points rather. According to verse
16, this is where we see the next power
rising. And he that cometh against him
shall do according to his own will, and
none shall stand before him, and he
shall stand in the glorious land, which
by his hand shall be consumed. Mikey, I
asked the question last time to you, and
I will repeat it again.
>> Who do you think or what territory do
you believe the glorious land
represents?
>> Jerusalem.
>> Jerusalem. Very good. In Jerusalem, now
this is this is the focus of attention
in verse 16. God is going it God has to
help us understand from this point on
what's happening with God's people
throughout the ages. Now this time if
we're talking about Rome we're talking
about the first phase of Rome which is
what phase of Rome Mikey
>> pagan Rome.
>> Okay. Now springboarding from from verse
11 all the way to verse 20. Please read
verse 20. Then shall stand up in his
estate a razor of taxes in the glory of
the kingdom, but within few days he
shall be destroyed, neither in anger nor
in battle.
Now Mikey, we covered this last time.
Remember the word taxes?
>> Okay. What kingdom
according to the Bible
had anything to do with taxes? At least
in the New Testament, what was the
kingdom?
>> Give unto Caesar that which is Caesar.
So Roman
It was Rome. Now read this, please. Luke
2:1.
>> And it came to pass in those days that
there went out a decree from Caesar
Augustus that all the world should be
taxed.
>> Okay? So we've we what we just did we ma
rather not what I did or what we did but
what God just just did was the
following. He made it clear to us what
kingdom is in power. Mhm.
>> All we do, all we have to do is attach
these two these two verses to say,
"Okay, Lord, I get it." And we're using
the Bible to understand that.
>> Now, if you go back to Daniel 11, you go
two verses later, you go to verse 22,
and the Bible reads as follows. And with
the arms of a flood shall they be
overflown from before them, and shall be
broken, yay, also the prince of a
covenant. Now, Mikey, who is this prince
of the covenant again? Jesus Christ.
>> It was none other than Jesus the Christ.
Now, let's go back to this verse because
there's another word that I that I
highlighted that word broken. What does
that word broken mean? Mikey, we talked
about it before.
>> Um, they shall be broken.
>> Okay. Let me ask this question. If it's
referring to the prince of the covenant
Oh.
>> and Jesus,
>> what does that imply?
>> That he was sacrificed.
He was sacrificed. Remember, and if you
would link up Daniel chapter 9 25- 26,
>> you will find as you stated, I I'll give
you the privilege to read it because
this is what you quoted last time. So go
ahead, read it.
>> Yeah. And Messiah the prince shall be
cut off.
>> Messiah the prince shall be cut off. So
now
was the prince of the covenant though he
was killed, Jesus was killed, did
Christianity lose or did it gain more
power and more momentum as a result of
his death?
>> Christianity definitely won.
>> Okay. And what happened was that
eventually eventually what we find is
that paganism eventually ties a knot or
sleeps in the same bed with true
Christianity. Okay. Now again, let's
just establish this point. I need to
establish this point. Was Jesus
destroyed? I mean, what I'm sorry, not
that's not the question. If Jesus was
destroyed, was did Christianity lose?
>> No, it didn't lose.
>> No, it didn't. Because you know that
three days later he resurrected and then
he gave the great commission. Go ye
therefore and teach all nations,
baptizing them in the name of the
father, the son, and the holy ghost,
teaching them to observe all things
whatsoever I have commanded you. And we
know according to acts chapter 8 and 2 I
mean chapter 8 2 and 4 and they went
everywhere preaching the word. So
because of persecution in Jerusalem
remember the Jews were starting to
persecute them. What we have now is that
that the Jew or rather the the apostles
and those disciples started to they were
forced to venture out to spread the
gospel for the love of the gospel. So
during the Roman Empire, you find that
Daniel's looking at a map and he
actually sees the spread of
Christianity. Now in the initial stages
of Christianity, that is at the time of
Christ with his disciples following and
preaching the message. You can read it
in acts acts chapter 2 on the day of
Pentecost, the message was spreading.
Okay, again anchor points that we have.
We had Greece. Now we come to pagan
Rome. pagan Rome all the way to 22. Now
in verses 22 I mean 23 to 24 something
happens to Christianity.
Mikey please read these part this these
verses here.
>> And after the league made with him he
shall work deceitfully for he shall come
up and shall become strong with a small
people. He shall enter peaceibly even
upon the fattest place of the province.
And he shall do that which his fathers
have not done, nor his father's fathers.
He shall scatter among them the prey and
spoil and riches. Yay, and he shall
forecast his devices against the
strongholds even for a time.
>> Okay. So what the ver these two verses
is simply telling us
>> something happened with Christianity as
discussed before and again for those
that are watching for the first time you
have to watch our previous um
presentation to get more context.
However I'm going to briefly um repeat
what I stated earlier. Okay. Now we
notice that the Bible says there's a
league made with them. That means
there's a there there's an agreement.
They're they're locking hands now but
they're doing it on the notion of
deceit. Christianity
in Christianity
or Christianity now declines. And I want
you to notice because this verse, these
two verses is actually springboarding.
It's it's gliding throughout the years.
And how do we know that? Because it says
that it starts off from a very small
people. It starts small and eventually
gets big. Did you catch that, Mikey?
>> Yeah.
>> It starts small, but it then it becomes
big. But this is from a people that
don't have really good intentions. And
the Bible specifically asks something
else to give us a better fine-tuned clue
to understand what's really taking place
because it then it goes on it goes on
then to say and he shall do that which
his fathers have not done nor his
father's fathers. In other words, their
ancestors, whatever their ancestors held
to the truth of the word of God, a thus
and thus sayith the Lord, now the
Christianity falls off a precipice, if
you will. And now there's deceit. This
Christianity puts on a mass like, oh,
we're saints, but in re in reality,
we're acting like devils. Are you
getting this, Mike?
>> Definitely.
>> So, think about all this is what I'm
saying. If you consider everything that
I'm saying, I asked a question before.
Let me repeat it to you, Mikey. Did a
certain form of Christianity work
deceitfully
>> and do that which his fathers have not
done nor his father's fathers.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Yes. Right.
>> So we came to understand that that there
was none other than peopleled
Christianity. Remember that.
>> Okay. So what we did or rather rather I
I said something earlier that I didn't
mean I put I said that that they locked
hands. I didn't mean that before. What
it was is that Christianity, let me
clarify what I meant before. Let me put
the slide up to so I can make sure that
I clarify because I said it wrong and I
want to make sure I clarify. So people
say, "Wait, hold on. According to this,
it doesn't sound like what what I was
saying."
>> This particular slide was when
Christianity was against paganism. I
didn't mean that. I spoke too soon. Now,
that was back then at the time of
Christ. Remember, paganism didn't care
about Christianity. But eventually
paganism joins forces with Christianity.
This is what I meant to say. So trying
to clarify the point. Does that make
sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now if you were to go to Daniel
chapter 7 again, Daniel, remember he
talks about these beasts. And if you
remember beasts represent kings or
kingdoms or political powers. And
speaking more specifically about the
fourth kingdom, we come to find out that
this beast represented pagan Rome. But
when Daniel was looking dead at the
beast, he saw something that really
shocked his nerves. He's looking at the
10 horns, and horns represent kingdoms
in which the kingdom of Rome by the year
476 AD splintered itself to 10 divisions
of Rome. But after 47, sometime after
476 AD, another's power is seen rising.
If you notice on your screen, Mikey,
what do you see there? You see another
horn rising.
>> A little horn.
>> Yes. And how many is it uprooting?
>> Uh, three.
>> Three. Right now, I want you to look
closely to that little horn. If you look
closely to that little horn, you're
going to notice something about this
little horn. What do you see now on that
horn? I
>> see a face on it.
>> See a face, right? The Bible talks about
that. This is This is what the Bible
actually says. and he shall speak great
words against the most high and shall
wear out the saints of the most high and
he shall think change times and laws.
We're going to get into that in just a
bit. Okay. But the Bible is telling us
that a system out of Rome that is
contrary to the previous that looks
contrary to the um by appearances that
is or appearance wise to the 10 previous
beasts I mean the 10 previous horns.
This horn has eyes like the eyes of a
man and a mouth speaking uh things great
things according to Daniel chapter 7:8.
And over here he speaks great words
against God. In other words, he's
against God's government and his being.
And not only that, he persecutes this
system under his rulership, persecutes
God's people, and he also attempts to
change God's laws. Now, question Mikey,
does God have a set of laws?
>> Oh, yeah. Ten Commandments.
>> Oh, he does. So, this is none other than
peopleled Christianity. the little horn
of Daniel chapter 7. Okay.
What Christian what what what um what um
sorry the Roman Catholic Church did back
at this time is that they join forces
with paganism in order to to receive
more of the people of the world. So now
let's go back to the map. You got
peopleled Christianity to the north.
Okay, you got and I mean it's just
clear. So now what we have here is papal
Rome paper Christianity as the fourth
anchor point. Mikey, if that's clear so
far, let me know.
>> Definitely.
>> Okay, let's look at the map again.
We have peopleled Christianity to the
north dominantly speaking to the north.
Okay, but the Bible says something else.
It says here in verse 25, we're gliding
through the through through the chapter.
And he shall stir up his power. That's
the king of the north. Because remember,
as I stated in our previous message or
presentation, anything that you see
highlighted in red represents the king
is referring to the king of the north.
And anything that you see highlighted to
the blue is referring to the king of the
south. The Bible says that he, the king
of the north, shall stir up his power
and his courage against the king of the
south with a great army. And the king of
the south shall be stirred up to battle
with a very great and mighty army. But
he shall not stand and they shall
forecast devices against him. So
question Mikey, I posed this question to
you the last time.
>> What question? I'm sorry. What specific
country was last said to be the king of
the south? I gave you a specific
location by name
>> south of Jerusalem.
>> Egypt.
>> Very good. It was Egypt. Now remember
the verse said here. It said here and
the the verse is said here and the king
of the south shall be strong and and the
south shall come to the king of the
north and shall also carry captives into
Egypt. He shall continue more years than
the king of the north. So at this only
time only time
before verse 40 that the Bible gives us
a specific named location. Period. And
it's specifically talking about the
south and that southern kingdom is
predominantly as at least by by way of
Daniel chapter 11 is or rather it comes
from Egypt. Now I asked a the following
question before I hope that you can
answer as you did before. Okay.
>> In the years of the rise of the civil
religious Roman Catholic church remember
it was a church and state institution.
Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Which here represented as a king of the
north. Did the king of the south which
is here as we came to find out is Egypt.
Did this kingdom of the south transition
itself to becoming a different civil and
religious entity as well?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> Okay. Now how do we know that?
Because when you add more information
verses 25 and 26
the Bible says as follow no go ahead
Mikey please read it. And he shall stir
up his power and his courage against the
king of the south with a great army. And
the king of the south shall be stirred
up to battle with a very great and
mighty army. But he shall not stand. For
they shall forecast devices against him.
Yay, they that feed of the portion of
his meat shall destroy him, and his army
shall overflow, and many shall fall down
slain.
>> Okay. So now, thank you Mikey. So what
these two verses is simply telling us is
giving us more context to the time
period of the church and state power.
But this is during the dark ages, if you
will. Okay, we came to understand that
this was the time period of the crusades
>> of the crusades.
>> Yeah.
>> Now again, Daniel's looking at a map.
While he's looking at the kingdom of the
north, he sees another power rising
that's coming from the south. And we
came to find out that that secondary
power was Islam, which was also a
spiritual and political power. Right,
Mikey? Wasn't a spiritual and because
they had their own belief, remember
Allah and their own teachings, they
believe that, but they also believe in
the conquest of these areas as well. So
here we're talking about Islamic world,
if you will. Okay, you look at this map.
Okay, now by the year of 1099,
we come to find out that the crusaders
finally conquered Jerusalem. We're going
to be talking about this a little bit
more in depth in our next in when we
come back to this presentation. I'm just
giving context again, okay? So, I'm not
going to be showing any videos
pertaining to this right now today.
The Bible says something. Now, here goes
the gem that I that I did not include in
our next meeting in our last meeting
that I'm going to include here. So, this
is you're going to hear this for the
first time and your audience is going to
hear this for the first time. Matter of
fact, I don't believe that I even
discussed this point on my personal
platform for years because I've always
left it out only for when I did it like
eight or 10 years ago, but I think it
will be relevant for today.
Even though that Rome did conquer
Jerusalem in 1099, Rome lost his seat
throughout the wars that eventually
unseated and dethroned them if you will
from Jerusalem and the um the Muslims
took power or took that seat and that
eventually became where the Dome of the
Rock was built. Now you've heard of the
Dome of the Rock, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So this back and forth that they had
these issues. Okay, with the Muslims,
with the Turks, with the Arabs during
all these years, the Bible tells us that
something happened as a result because
they're they're not able to reconquer
this area. This is what the Bible says.
Now, for the audience, this is the first
time that I'm going to present this
other gem to help highlight issues that
was taking place during this time
period. The Bible says the following in
verse 28. The Bible says, "And he shall
return into his land with great riches,"
that's the king of the north, "and his
heart shall be against." Now Mikey, read
the remaining part of or let's read
that. Matter of fact, you read it from
the beginning. Go ahead, read it.
>> Okay. Then shall he return to his land
with great riches, and his heart shall
be against the holy covenant, and he
shall do exploits and return to his own
land.
So if this is talking about the papacy
because that's referring to the king of
the north.
>> Mhm.
>> And it says within himself now he's
going to conjure up something that's
going to strike against what? Again?
>> The holy covenant.
>> This does that sound spiritual to you?
>> Uh yeah sounds. Yeah.
>> Now this is a literal entity that the
Bible says is going to go against the
holy covenant. So naturally speaking,
>> what is this holy covenant? I'm just
going to give two verses to try to make
sense out of it. Again, we're going to
talk more about it later on because I
want to get to the latter part.
>> This is going to help your readers. This
is going to help your listeners and your
audience to understand at least this
clause of Daniel chapter 11. Now, in
order to identify what is the holy
covenant, most a lot of us already know
somewhat the answer, but let's just glue
the two verses together. If you go to
the New Testament, Hebrews 8:10, the
Bible says as follows. For this is the
what, Mikey?
>> The the covenant
>> that I will make with the house of
Israel after those days, sayaeth the
Lord, and I will put my what?
>> Laws
>> in their where?
>> Their mind.
>> He's going to write them where
>> in their hearts.
>> And then he says, I will be to them a
god, and they should be to me a people.
So, I want you to know the language.
We're just using the Bible. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> We're using Bible. We're we're trying to
attach words together. Okay. Mhm.
>> The Bible uses the word a covenant. And
that covenant is what?
>> Is his laws
>> and he's going to place it where?
>> In our minds and in our hearts.
>> In our minds and our hearts. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, I want you to notice what Paul also
writes. Now, the the writer to the book
of Hebrews is believed to be Paul. Okay?
Now, you read Romans chapter 7:12, the
Bible says the following. Go ahead, read
this. Wherefore my law is holy and the
commandment holy and just and good.
>> So if you go to Hebrews chapter 8 verse
10 and it says here that the covenant is
his laws and he says here Romans chapter
7 that the law is holy. What do you
think this was referring to?
>> The ten commandments.
>> The ten commandments. Now somebody may
say oh so are you saying that they were
against the commandments? Well, if you
go back to Daniel chapter 7, it gave you
that clue. Remember, I read it earlier.
Go ahead and read this.
>> And he shall speak great words against
the most high, and he shall think to
change times and laws.
>> That tells us that he was against
something that was holy, something that
does not even pertain to them. Are you
noticing this, Mikey?
>> Oh, yeah. Now, if you were to take the
converts catechism of Catholic doctrine,
this is the book that they go from door
to door to try to make converts. Okay,
there's a question that pose they pose a
question in this book that hits the
heart of the ten commandments. Now,
again, we're going to talk more about
this later on, not today. Okay? Now, in
that book, there's a question and it
says, "Which is the Sabbath day?" In
that same book, they give you the
answer. It says, "Saturday is the
Sabbath day." All right? They then ask
why do we that is the Roman Catholic
Church observe Sunday instead of
Sabbath? They answer the Catholic Church
did what?
>> Transferred the simnity from Saturday to
Sunday.
>> So the word transferred also means what?
>> Changed.
>> Doesn't that sound like this is what
happened here?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So they're against the holy
covenant of God. Is am I making sense
with what I'm saying, Mikey?
>> Yeah. This is all line upon line.
>> Okay. So that means they struck they
they were they were hard set to try to
eradicate something from the law of God.
>> This is during the time period of their
internal struggle with the reformation.
Remember that?
>> Yep.
>> This was the spiritual element that they
had to deal with with the faction
within. This was more of the
insurrection from their own people
because they were going against them
because of the word of God.
>> The Bible stated in in Daniel 11:32 and
33. Go ahead and read that.
>> But the people that do know their God
shall be strong, and they that shall and
they that understand among the people
shall instruct many.
>> Shall instruct what?
>> Many.
>> Shall instruct many. Now, I gotta ask a
question. When the Bible's saying that
it's going to instruct many, by what
book, you think they're going to
instruct many? Instruct
>> the word of God.
>> The word of God, right?
>> The word of God. So, if they're going to
they're going to instruct the word of
God, I mean, right? They're going to use
the book to instruct the people, rather.
If you're gonna use the word of God to
instruct the people, you think that
they're going to have it easy to do so
during this dark age period?
>> No.
>> No. No. Not at all. Now, I want you to
understand something else. The Bible
then goes on to say,
"Yet, sorry, I'm trying to get the
pace." Okay. Yet they shall fall by the
sword and by flame and by captivity and
by spoil. How many days?
>> Many days.
>> Oh, many days. Yeah.
>> And then read the next text. This is
coming from Revelation 12:11. So I'm
taking something else from the last book
of the Bible. And I want you to
understand what happened to God's people
during this time period.
>> And they overcame him by the blood of
the lamb and by the word of their
testimony. And they love not their lives
unto the death.
>> They love not their lives unto death.
I really I don't know what else to
really say but but but one thing only is
that these people stood for the word of
God even if their lives depended upon
it.
>> Amen.
>> Now it's interesting. Now let me pause
here. This is where we fail to use the
word of God and to make this our
textbook,
right? We failed to use it. That blood
was spilled for us to have this book
today. Back then it was so hard for you
to obtain a Bible, let alone just a page
or a leaflet of the Bible. People were
willing to dine for this book or a page
of this book where today we barely even
want to sometimes spend time with this
book. Shame of us. It's it's just such a
shame. You can today go to Dollar
General. You can go to Dollar Tree. You
can find a book for 10. I mean for a
dollar.
>> Yeah.
>> You can go to Goodwill 50 cents
>> free.
>> You can go thale and get it for free.
Thrift stores are given to you for free,
man.
>> For free. And the thing is, do we really
take our Bible? Now, I'm not saying
everybody's that way, but a lot of us
don't value that book.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, this particular this this section
of um Daniel chapter 11, we dealt with
the last our last meeting. Then we go to
the final part in this first well in
this section and dealing with the first
section that is. And um I have the wrong
let here. Let me let me fix that up real
quick. Um,
>> okay.
>> 11. I have that incorrect.
>> Good. I
>> Yes. Here we go.
Okay. Can you see it?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. In Daniel 11:40,
the Bible says, "And at the time of the
end shall the kings of of the south push
at him, and the king of the north shall
come against him like a whirlwind with
chariots and with horsemen and with many
ships."
Now, this is the area that I'm just
going to let you in on. This is the area
where a lot or some people from my
church
believe something different to what I
presented in our last meeting.
>> We're going to get into the nitty-gritty
of the identification of who is actually
the king of the south, which I believe I
already established who's the king of
the north. I also believe I established
personally I believe I established well
who was the king of the the south as
well.
>> But for argument sake this is what
today's meeting is. You were going to
say something.
>> No I was just going to say I think you
made it very clear from the Bible
geography history that the king of the
north is uh papal Rome and the king of
the south is Islam. But I did see a lot
of those comments from people that were
kind of triggered and upset that you
said that and I I was curious as to why.
I'm like, why is this such a a tough
topic here?
Very good. So now most of those people
that are probably um upset or probably
um not happy because of what I'm
presenting is because they have a
different belief than to the one that I
hold to. And that's fine. And that's
what we're going to be discussing today.
But even for the sake of your audience,
I understood that when I was going to
discuss that point, I have to also try
to teach those that are going to be very
sincere and coming into this for the
first time. Are you following what I'm
saying?
>> So I had to make sure that I lined it
out completely and as thoroughly as it
possible. So what we need to understand
when the Bible makes it very clear that
Catholicism was against the law of God
and they were trying to do away with the
law of God, there was another system in
history that not only tried to do away
with the law of God. And when I say do
away with the law of God, they they
changed it. They weren't totally totally
completely against it, but there was a
system that not only was against the
word of God, but had was totally against
everything that had to deal with God or
Christianity.
>> Now, that is found in Revelation 11. And
that's what we're going to talk on right
now. God, I mean, war on God's word.
Now, we're going to read several verses,
14 verses just to get context context
and then we're going to break these
down. Again, this is a part of the study
that there are also people that believe
probably not even from the church that I
belong to or I'm affiliated with, but
there are also different beliefs as to
the identity of some concepts that are
drawn out in this particular chapter.
And we'll get to it in just a minute. So
let's go now to the book of revelation
11:es 1-14. Now we're dealing with the
extra part. Okay. Now we're going to
give a study
on what or who is what system is in
power in Revelation 11:es 1-14. Okay.
Let's just start reading. And there was
given given me a reed like unto a rod
and an angel stood saying rise and
measure the temple of God and the altar
and them that worship therein. But the
court which is without the temple, leave
out, and measure it not, for it is given
unto the Gentiles. And the holy city
shall they tread underfoot 40 and two
months. And I will give power unto my
two witnesses, and they shall prophesy
1,23
score days clothed in sackcloth. It
continues to say, "These are the two
olive trees and the two candlesticks
standing before the God of the earth.
And if any man will hurt them, fire
proceedth out of their mouth and
devourth their enemies. And if any man
will hurt them, he must in this manner
be killed. These have power to shut
heaven, that it rain not in the days of
their prophecy, and have power over
waters to turn them to blood, and to
smite the earth with all plagues as
often as they will. There are people
that actually believe this to be so
literal. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> On. And when they shall have finished
their testimony, that is the two
witnesses, the beast that ascendant out
of the bottom out of the bottomless pit
shall make war against them and shall
overcome them and kill them. Now folks,
to those that are watching the thumbnail
that you initially saw leading up to
this today's presentation, two those two
men that you saw fire breathing out,
this is what this is referring to.
That's why Mikey put that out there so
you know that this that picture that
thumbnail was referring to the chapter
of Revelation 11
>> dealing with the two witnesses. Okay.
Now continuing on. And their dead
bodies, the two witnesses
shall lie in the street of the great
city and which spiritually is called
Sodom and Egypt where also our Lord was
crucified. And they of the people and
kindreds and tongues and nations shall
see their dead bodies three days and a
half and shall not suffer their dead
bodies to be to be put in graves. We're
getting ready to close with all this.
And they that dwell upon the earth shall
rejoice over them. In other words, when
they see, that's what it says here. Then
when they see the dead bodies there in
the streets and make merry and shall
sound gifts one to another because these
two prophets tormented them that dwelt
on earth. And after three days and a
half, the spirit of life from God
entered into them, and they stood upon
their feet, and great fear fell upon
them which saw them, and they heard a
great voice from heaven, saying unto
them, "Come up hither." And they
ascended, that means they went up into
heaven in a cloud, and their enemies
beheld them.
And the same hour was there a great
earthquake, and the temp part of the
city fell, and in the earthquake were
slain of men 7,000. And the remnant were
afrighted and gave glory to to the God
of heaven.
>> Now, folks, this is what we need to
start dealing with because we're going
to start from the top now, Mikey. Okay?
>> So, we read all the way to verse 14
here. Now, what we're going to do is
start from the top. Now, all I'm going
to do here, not to try not to make it as
exhaustive as it can be, not every
detail that I'm going to explain. I'm
just wanting to get to the major points
to understand what Revelation 11 is
talking about versus what it's not
talking about. And then what I'm going
to do is I'm going to talk to more of my
church's audience to what Daniel 11
verse 40 is saying and versus what it's
not saying. Did did you understand what
I just said?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, what are the highlighted um
words that you see here? Go ahead and
read the highlighted words.
>> 40 and two months, 1,23
score days.
>> Okay. So, there obviously those are time
prophecies. Would you agree?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So, we got to naturally ask the
question, what are 42 months and 1,200
um 260 days? Now Mikey, for your
audience, for the sake of your audience
that have never understood this, this is
why I felt like I needed to make sure I
gave them a Bible study. Does that make
sense?
>> Yeah.
>> We got because if I just talk about the
latter part, they're not going to
understand the former. So, right,
>> we got to identify this. So, let me try
to break it down as simple as possible.
Now, when terms of time prophecy, I
didn't discuss it in the last meeting.
For those that are joining us again,
you're going to understand how this
works. Let's get let let's get going.
Okay. When dealing with prophetic time,
one must consider another method that
the Bible uses to better our
understanding in what the words days and
months actually means. Now, to unlock
this concept of what a day means or what
months mean, we have to use the Bible to
give us the keys that unlocks this
mystery. If you go to the book of
numbers chapter 14:34, this was the time
period that Moses was about to enter
into the promised land. But remember
that there was 10 spies that he sent
before. They came back to bring a
report. But 10 of them started to
discourage the people where two of them
Joshua and Caleb said, "No, we can go
ahead and take over." But because the
majority failed to exercise their faith,
God now condemned or cursed them. And
the Bible says here after the number of
the days in which ye shall ye search the
land even 40 days. And what does it say
um there?
>> Each day for a year.
>> Each day for a year. So he told them you
guys are going to wonder the wilderness
for 40 days. But let me be clear. I'm
saying I I really mean what?
>> 40 years.
>> 40 years. Now, another verse that you
can use to unlock the mystery of what a
day actually means is found in Ezekiel
4:6. I have appointed thee. And what
does it say, Mikey?
>> Each day for a year.
>> Each day a year. So, according to the
Bible, okay, one prophetic day equals
one literal a year. Ezekiel 4:6 and
Numbers 14:34. So when we read the
concept about the 1260 days, it actually
means what, Mikey?
>> 1260 years. I want to add one more point
cuz I don't know if you're going to
cover it, but
>> in the prophecy in Daniel 9 when it
talks about it's pointing to Christ uh
baptism, death,
>> and the gospel going out to the
Gentiles. It says se it says um in the
midst of the week. And yet we know that
that's not a literal 7-day week. It's a
seven-year week that Christ was
crucified in in the middle of that seven
uh seven years.
>> And and and Mikey, again, thank you for
stopping me on that point. This is why.
And you know, I thought I really started
to think it even more so after our last
meeting of when you interjected and you
stated the issue about the seven-year
tribulation. And I said, you know, I
even talked to you afterward. I said,
thank you for for bringing that up or at
least stopping me to emphasize on that
point because really that's the prophecy
that we also need to understand. As a
matter of fact, let me tell you
something. And I was looking through my
paperwork at home just the other day and
I came across a list of paper I mean
some paperwork that I actually submitted
to u my local newspaper several years
back
and I entitled the series um is was
Jesus an impostor? And you know what I
did
>> for several weeks I talked about Daniel
chapter 7 and it came out in a newspaper
article.
>> That is awesome.
>> I never got anybody to rebut it either.
>> Wow.
>> Cuz I was so clear crystal clear to that
point. As a matter of fact, if anybody
wants to get that article or the the
list of um the articles that I ended up
um putting out there, just get with me
and then of course I will try to get it
to you by PDF format. Okay. So um or if
they want to, they can wait until we
have the meeting and then we'll put it
out there. Is that right? And as a
matter of fact, I I'll share with you um
when we get to that meeting. Is that all
right, Mikey?
>> Sounds great.
>> Okay. Because again, we want to teach
many people. This is not our message.
This is God's message.
>> Amen.
>> Okay. I don't know why people try to
hoard it. No, this is it's time for us
to release everything that we got.
>> Time is running out.
>> Okay, so now we covered the the days
aspect. Days actually equals years
equals years. Now, how about the 42
months?
This is something that people don't seem
to grasp or or be able to wrap their
heads around. But I'm going to make it
as simple possible for you to understand
that actually the 42 months is equal to
the 1260 days. How do we how do we know
that? Well,
since this time prophecy was given to
John the Revelator, a Jew, we must then
calculate this time prophecy by using
the same lunar calendar. Let me repeat
again, lunar, not solar
>> calendar system that John would use.
Remember, the Jews used lunar calendars.
Now,
>> the Jews used a 30day calendar.
Let me repeat that again. They use
30-day calendar months instead of the 28
to 31 day calendar months that we use
because we go by solar calendar,
>> you know, not not not the Jews, at least
not back then. Now, let's look at this
is simple math. Simple math. Okay,
remember a day equals a year. Okay, so
you have 42 months. The Bible says what
you're going to need to do, and those
that need to learn, please write it down
while you're watching, is you're going
to learn how to unlock what 42 months
actually means. 42 months. You times it
by 30 days.
This is the formula. Months times days
will then eventually equal to years.
That's your formula right there.
>> Okay.
>> Times that, Mikey. What? See if you can
time it. Put it Write it down. Do you
have
>> Math's my worst one, but I'm following.
>> Okay. So, okay. Math wasn't good for me
either.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> But look. Okay. So, you got it's simple
math. 42 * 30 it equals to none other
than 1260 years. Remember the formula is
month time days equals years.
>> So we have a total of 1260 years
>> years
>> just like we had with the other um um
the other um um clause that Revelation
11 just gave us. Now the 1260 years
started in the year of 538 AD and ended
in the year 1798 AD. We're going to
cover this in full details in our next
meeting, not today. I'm going to give
some context to it, but I want you to
understand for starters 1260 years began
in 538 AD and it ended in 1798 AD. Now,
this is a time period that the Bible
says that something is going to be
taking place with the two witnesses
within this this time period.
>> Now, let's go back to the text. The
Bible says here, "And I will give power
unto my two witnesses, and they shall
prophesy for 1,23 score days." Mikey,
1,263
score days is equal to what in years?
>> 1260 years.
>> Okay. So within that that time period,
the Bible says that whoever these two
witnesses, we haven't identified it yet.
Whoever these two witnesses are going to
be able to do something within the time
period of 1260 years, but I want you to
notice it says clothed in sackcloth.
We're going to get to that in just a
bit.
>> These are the two what, Mikey?
>> Olive trees.
These are the two olive trees and the
two candlesticks standing before the God
of the earth. Now, that's the point that
we need to hit on right now. Okay,
>> we need to hit on. So, what is this
about the two candlesticks? We got to
understand that. Well, the only way to
identify which are the two candlesticks,
okay, and the two olive trees, we got to
go into the Bible. We're going to go
into Zechariah 4:2. Now, this is what
the Bible says in the Old Testament. I
want you to notice because remember John
is writing, but he's also getting
imagery sent to him by way of a vision,
but a lot of what he writes, a high
percentage of what he writes in the book
of Revelation, you can find it in the
Old Testament.
>> Yeah.
>> This is what he says here. And said unto
me, what seeth thou? Now, this is
Zachchariah speaking to the angel. This
is he's in vision as well. And I said, I
have looked and behold a what?
>> Candlestick
>> of L of gold with a bowl upon the top of
it and his seven what? Um Mikey,
>> lamps.
>> So you got a candlestick and you got
lamps. Yes or no?
>> Yep.
>> There on and seven pipes to the seven
lamps which are upon the top. So let's
deal with this candlestick which was
actually a lamp as well. Let's deal with
that. in the Bible. Have you ever heard
of this this verse? And I want you to
read this verse. Go ahead.
>> Thy word is a lamp unto my feet and a
light unto my path.
>> Now remember, their light was candles,
wasn't it? Back then, did they have
flashbacks that we had today?
>> No.
>> So, thy word, what does it say?
>> Thy word is a lamp unto my feet and a
light into my path.
>> So, there's a lamp, a candlestick. So,
what is the lamp and the candlestick?
>> God's word. Yeah, it's his word.
>> It's his word. Very good. Well, how
about this? In Psalms 119 verse1 130,
what does it say here?
>> The entrance of thy words giveth light.
It giveth understanding unto the simple.
Wow.
>> Is is is that not true for us today as
well?
>> Amen.
>> It is right. Let's go back to the text.
Okay. These are the two what it says
there?
>> Witnesses.
>> Olive trees.
>> Oh, wait. Olive trees.
>> And the two what?
>> Candlesticks. handle. Let's go back to
the book of Zechariah. Okay. In the book
of Zechariah, it says, "And two what?"
There
olive trees.
>> Now, I want you to notice we're
connecting the links
by it, one upon the right side of the
boat, and the other upon the left side
thereof. So, I answered and spake unto
the angel that talked with me, saying,
"What are these, my Lord?" So, he's
looking in vision. He sees two olive
trees and he's asking what are these?
Now remember we're looking at we're
we're visualizing it at the time of
Zechariah where they would actually have
those olive today. We don't really
understand the agricultural aspect
because many of us are not uh
agriculturally um savvy.
>> Okay, because we don't deal grocery
markets deal with all that. We just go
over there, pay the bill and then we
bring the food home. But that's not how
necessarily it was for the most part
back then. So you have olive trees. So
this is what's coming to me. So I can
relate to that. See most places
especially like in the time of Christ
when he gave parables he gave it in with
um agricultural ter tones
>> terminology they could relate to it. You
follow what I'm saying?
>> Today if Jesus with us probably he will
use skyscrapers, cars, automobiles,
planes because this is something that we
can relate to. Right?
>> So this is what's envisioned at the time
of Zachchariah.
>> He sees an olive tree. Now let's just go
a little bit further here. Okay? I want
you to notice he says, "And the two
olive trees by it, one upon the right
side of the bowl and the other upon the
left side of the of thereof. So I
answered and spake unto the angel and
talked with me, saying, "What are these,
my Lord?" And I want you to notice,
Mikey, I want you to read this. I want
you to read the following. I want you to
notice what the angel tells him. This is
the response. Remember the question is
about the what?
>> The olive trees, right?
>> Okay. I want you to notice what the
angel how the angel responds. Read it.
>> Then he answered and spake unto me,
saying, "Not by might, nor by power, but
by my spirit, saith the Lord of hosts.
These are the two anointed ones that
stand by the Lord of the whole earth."
Wow.
>> Hold up a second. So, we understand that
the light and the lamp or the
candlestick represents the word of God.
The Bible just says that the two olive
um branches trees
represent the spirit,
>> the anointing. Now remember when Jesus
came on the scene and he was about to do
the work in Luke 4:1 18. Go ahead and
read that.
>> The spirit of the Lord is upon me, but
because he hath anointed me to preach
the gospel to the poor. So, was Jesus
also anointed?
>> Yes,
>> he was anointed, wasn't he?
>> So, this is this Mikey, we see what
we're doing is what the at least what
the Bible is attempting to help us do is
we're unlocking the mystery of these
particular words. They're using these
words to employ an idea of something.
So, what are we understanding? We are
understanding then that the two
witnesses refer to the Old and New
Testaments. Is that is that making sense
to you?
>> Yeah. Yeah, it is.
>> Okay. It's it's about that. Now, it's
very interesting. You can read the
Bible. It says ye and this is Jesus
speaking to the multitudes. Ye ye search
the scriptures.
>> But because ye think that in them ye
have what?
>> Eternal life.
>> And these are they which bear of me or
bear witness to me. In other words, he
says to the people, you you guys got
your scrolls and you believe it gives
you all the power and everything like
that, but let me tell you something.
Those scriptures that you're reading
reveal me. It's about me. That's what
he's saying to the people. Am I right?
>> Witnesses.
>> Exactly. They bear witness of me.
>> Wow.
>> That's what the scriptures do for us.
Are you getting this? Um
>> yeah, this is making a lot of sense.
>> All right. Now he remember he also Jesus
says this and this gospel of the kingdom
shall be preached in all the world for a
witness unto all nations and then the
end shall come for what gospel gospel of
the kingdom.
>> Okay. Now where do we get the gospel?
Where do we hear the gospel from?
>> The word of God.
>> It's from this.
>> Yes or no?
>> The scriptures. Yep.
>> Okay. Now I want you to notice something
about this though. There's going to be a
decline because the Bible says they were
going to prophesy within the 1260 years,
but they were going to prophesy in a
certain way or manner.
Mikey, please read the following text.
>> And I will give power unto my two
witnesses, and they shall prophesy, 123
score days clothed in sackcloth.
Now, we're going to understand if the
two witnesses represented the word of
God, both the Old and the New Testament,
because those are the anointed ones,
they're the ones that have power to turn
nations upside down. Yes or no?
>> Yes.
>> It has power to also help you be
converted. Yes or no?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. The Bible says during this time
period something was going to happen
that they were going to prophesy but
they were going to prophesy clothed in
what? Sackloth.
>> So let's now talk about this terminology
of sackcloth.
Let's get the understanding of what this
all actually means. Okay.
The Bible says here I'm going to give
you two stories. Jacob and Joseph.
Remember the story of the the the 12
patriarchs of Jo of Jacob.
>> Mhm. Remember Jacob gave um Joseph the
coat of many colors? You remember that
story?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. What happened with the brothers as
a result? Were they happy about it?
>> They hated him.
>> They hated that man with a passion.
Right.
>> Yeah. He was like the favored.
>> Exactly. They hated him. They felt that
he was the one that was spoiled. And as
a result, we come to find out that when
and when you read in the book of
Genesis, one day his father Jacob
dispatches his own son to go meet up
with his brothers. When they see him
from a distance, are they happy to see
him or they're plotting to do something
to him?
>> Yeah, they don't want to see him.
>> They don't want to see him, right?
>> They take him immediately. They strip
him off with the coat of many colors and
they place him into a what?
>> Into a well. big hole in the ground
>> until the wall, right? And then
eventually they see the Midianites or
the Israelites coming. And now they
concoct another idea because Reuben
didn't want to go ahead and kill him.
But he leaves plotting to actually
desiring to take him out of the pit and
release him. But while he's gone, the
other brothers see them,
>> the Midionites, the Israelites that is
with their caravan. And what do they do?
They plan to do what to Mo um to Joseph?
>> Sell him into slavery.
>> Sell him into slavery. He was taken into
slavery. And remember the thing that was
left behind was the code of many colors.
But they brought it back to the father.
They have to come up with some plan to
tell them what you know make up some
some story to what happened to their son
to to their brother to the younger baby
brother. They present the coat of many
colors to him but saturated in what?
>> Blood. Goat's blood. Right.
>> Was Jacob happy?
>> No.
>> He wasn't happy. This is what the Bible
says. And Jacob rented and put
sackcloth. What did he put?
>> Sackloth.
>> I want you to notice. He put sackcloth
upon his loins. And what happened as a
result of him putting sackcloth?
>> He was mourning.
>> Morning. What does it mean to mourn?
>> To grieve.
>> To grieve. Now, this is all terminology
that the Bible is trying to convey to us
about a something that happened during
this time period with the word of God.
But I'm just giving you context to
understand what the sackcloth actually
means. It meets a state of mourning, of
sorrow,
>> dark ages.
>> What do you think?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, let me give you another story
of on Queen Esther. Now, remember Queen
Esther, she rose to power by way of a
campaign that was out there to go ahead
and choose the next queen of Israel
because um Bashi, she didn't like what
her husband um was doing, Xerxes was
doing. he was going to try to parade her
but actually he wanted to parade her
naked that is and she was not going to
lower her her morale to that to that
state. So of course he chose another
woman but we also know during that story
that there was a another guy by the name
of what
>> I'm not sure
>> remember the story there was another guy
that wanted them killed. Okay.
>> And this individual, excuse me, hold on
a second. Let me get my water here. This
individual,
this indiv, can you hear me?
>> Yeah, I can hear you.
>> So, this individual concocts an idea
with the king.
And then what happens is he makes the
king sign a letter,
a a decree that was going to get ready
to stamp out all the Jews. You remember
that story?
>> Yeah.
Okay. And when Mori hears that, Morai is
the uncle of um Esther. When Mori hears
about it, this is what the Bible says. I
want you to I'm sorry, I went too far.
Go ahead.
>> When Mori perceived all that was done,
Mori rent his clothes and put on
sackcloth with ashes and went out into
the midst of the city and cried with a
loud and bitter cry.
>> Okay. So, question. Do you think he was
crying cuz he was happy?
>> No, he was uh he was bitter bitter
crying.
>> Okay. And then what does the Bible say
that he that he put on?
>> Sackloth.
>> He put on what?
>> Put on sackcloth.
Sackloth. And then he goes into the
state of mourning.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
Now I want you to notice in Isaiah 22:13
it says the following. And in the day
and in that day did the Lord God of
hosts call to weeping and to what?
>> Mourning.
>> And to baldness and to girding with
what?
>> Sackloth.
>> But you notice that the word sackloth is
also cojoined with something that is
depressing, that is mourning, that is in
a state of weeping. It goes, are you
understanding what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. Are you are you this? So are so
far. Are you understanding all of this
that I'm presenting to you?
>> Yep. Sackloth equals mourning and
grieving.
>> Grieving. Now remember, we're talking
about two witnesses. A time period that
now is bad enough that is the dark ages
within that time span of 1260 years. But
the Bible's telling us, no, you didn't
see anything yet. There was going to
come a time period that these it was
like almost to the point of death.
>> Yeah. that these that these that these
two witnesses the word of God was
feeling that you know it's like almost
all hope is lost.
>> Now the word sack cloth okay comes from
a hit number 4526
which basically means a coarse black
cloth commonly made of the long hair of
goats of goats and called mohair used
for straining for sacks and for mourning
garments. So they literally had garments
just to mourn.
>> Wow.
>> Did you get it? Yeah.
>> In the latter case, it was worn instead
of the ordinary garments or bound around
the loins of or spread under a person on
the ground. So now we just covered what
we're doing here. We're covering the
fact that these things these two
witnesses had to go through something
during the dark ages. The 1260 years
starting from 538 AD to 1798 AD was the
period of what again Mikey?
>> Dark ages.
During that same time period, we had
that little horn that was operating and
he shall speak great words against the
most high and and and and and shall wear
out the saints of the most high and
think to change times and laws. But I'm
going to tell you something. This power
that's going to actually go against
God's word is actually going to go
against the Catholic Church itself.
>> Very interesting. People don't even know
this.
>> This is how bad and demonic it gets. And
I'm going to show you how demonic it
actually gets. Okay? how demonic this
actually gets. Let me just make sure I'm
giving you the right slide here. Okay.
All right. So, let me go now to the next
slide. Okay. So, we understood that the
two olive branches, let me get to this
text. The two olive trees, forgive me,
okay, represent the spirit of God, okay,
which indeed represents the Holy Spirit.
We got that clear, right, Mikey?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So, now let's look at Revelation
11:es 4-6.
Well, verse 4-6, but I'm just going to
um for the sake of time, I'm just going
to read the highlighted the more
highlighted area.
No, I think I need to read everything.
It says here, and these are the two
olive trees, just to get context, and
the two candlesticks standing before the
God of the earth. And if any man will
hurt them, fire proceedth out of their
mouth and devourth their enemies. And if
any man will hurt them, he must in this
manner be killed. Now I want you to
notice speaking of the two or
>> these have power to shut heaven and that
it not what
>> rain
>> in the days of their prophecy and have
power over waters to turn them to blood
and to smite the earth with all plagues
as often as they will. So what the
Bible's telling us is giving us another
clue to understand something that
happened back then. However, this is
where a lot of people misunderstand this
particular prophecy. or we I'll explain
it in just a moment. Now, I want you to
notice these have power to shut heaven
that it rain not in the days of their
prophecy. Now, question Mikey, do you
ever remember of a prophet that actually
prophesied that there was not going to
be no rain?
>> Yeah, it was Elijah, right?
>> Very good. Remember the time of Elijah
and Ahab?
>> Yeah.
>> So, it's using a storyline to convey an
idea. Now, I'm going to tell you this
right now. There are people that believe
that these two witnesss are actually
gonna come back to life. I don't believe
that.
>> Right?
>> I'm gonna I'm gonna prove that in just a
bit. Okay? But for the sake of this
text, it says it does use the word these
have um power to shut heaven and it rain
not in the days of their prophecy. Okay.
So, we're going to deal with this first
part of the sentence. We're dealing with
the time of Elijah, the prophet Elijah.
remember when he came to Ahab and
because of um um the decline of
spirituality in in in in Israel what
happened now Elijah sent by God and he
tells them there's going to be a famine
and we know for three and a half years
there was a great famine felt and
according to second Kings chapter 2
verse1 15 the Bible says and when the
sons of the prophets saw him they said
the spirit of who
>> Elijah
>> thus rest on Elisha Now, this is the
latter part, granted, but I want you to
understand the spirit of who?
>> Elijah.
>> It's here in this text. It's not talking
about literal Elijah. It says the
spiritual Elijah. Right
>> now, back to this because we're going to
we're going to um try to identify the
second clause. So, the second part of
the senses. And it goes on to say, "And
have power over waters to turn them to
blood." I want you to notice Mikey
>> powers to turn waters into blood and to
smite the earth with all plagues as
often as they will. Question. Was there
ever a prophet
>> that turned water into blood and there
was plagues that came upon them?
>> Moses.
>> Very good. It was Moses, right? Remember
the Nile River, the first plague that
took place.
>> Okay.
Now, according to the book of Numbers, I
want you to notice what it says here.
And the Lord said unto Moses, "Is the
Lord's hand waxed short?" Now, this is
not talking about that story. I'm just
trying to get points out of this. That
is,
>> is the Lord's hand waxed short, that
thou shalt see now whether my word shall
come to pass unto thee or not? And the
Lord came down in a cloud and spake unto
him, and took of the spirit that was
upon him.
>> Wow.
>> I want you to I'm using these two texts
that deals with Elijah's spirit. Moses
spirit for a certain reason. Why?
Because get to Revelation 11 7 and 8.
The Bible tells us something about this
spirit
because this is where we're losing it
and we're going to get into and this is
very important for us to analyze
dealing with the time period. What time
period am I referring to?
>> The dark here.
>> The dark ages. Very good. During that
time period, something is happening to
God's word that they're now at the state
of mourning. In other words, they feel
that they're about to be extinct.
Remember what happened with Esther with
Hmon and and and and Xerxes? Remember
that Mori we just
>> it was a state that they felt that they
were about to come become extinct.
>> Okay. Now the Bible says here something
that's going to rise and when they shall
have finished their testimony
in reality the Bible the actual
understanding and rendering of the text
it should be when they're about
finishing their testimony remember they
have 12 years so at the closing when
it's about to be finished that's what
the text actually should render the the
beast that ascendeth where Mikey
>> out of the bottomless pit
>> shall make war against them. That's two
witnesses. And shall overcome them and
kill them. Are you noticing what the
Bible's telling us? Something's
happening in history.
>> Yeah. The witnesses are killed.
>> And read the last sentence here.
>> And their dead bodies shall lie in the
street of the of the great city which
spiritually is called Sodom and Egypt
where also our Lord was crucified.
Now, we're going to cover this because
we need to identify the players that are
mentioned here. But let's deal with the
first one that says here, the beast that
ascendeth out of the bottomless pit.
Now, question. What do we say a beast
represented in Bible prophecy?
>> A king or a kingdom.
>> Very good. I want you to notice the
Bible saying another beast rises.
>> But I want you to understand that this
beast is only going to rise for a short
period.
But where were these beasts? The beasts
that you see here over here, where were
these beasts seen rising from? Do you
remember
>> the sea?
>> Very good. In Daniel 7 2 and 3, the
Bible says, "I saw in my night in my
vision by night, and four great beasts
came up from the sea, a body of waters
diverse one from another." Now, what do
what does the terminology se mean? Do
you do you remember, Mikey?
>> Yeah. many people's people's multitudes,
nations and tongues.
>> Very good. When you when you look at
Revelation 17 verse 15, the Bible says,
"And he saith unto me, the waters which
thou sawest are peoples and na and
multitudes and nation and tongues." In
other words, it's a vastly populated
area. That's all that the terminology
see um um that's what the terminology of
the word sea means. However,
where is this or is the beast of
Revelation 11 scene coming out of
>> uh the bottomless pit?
>> Out of the bottomless pit. Now, I want
you to notice this is something very
significant.
>> The word pit basically means it has no
foundation.
How do we know?
>> Well, let's look at that word bottomless
pit. Pit. It's more the latter part of
this phrase. Pit. What does that word
actually mean? Well, let me I had to
make sure that I I understood it
correctly. And for you to understand,
I'm not making this up. It comes from
the Greek word abusos.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> You ever heard of the abyss?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. An extremely deep place. It occurs
only twice outside the book of
Revelation. And then it goes on to say
the prison destined for evil spirits. I
want you to note that this is all the
con rather things are actually happening
if you will in revelation 11 literally
happening but the way that is h the way
that is being described is being
described more in spiritual spiritual
terms in other words this is symbolic
imagery does that make sense
>> olive trees you got candlesticks
>> you get what I'm saying this
>> again we got to be careful because
there's a group of people out there in
Christianom that believe that these two
witnesses are literal people that are
going to show up. No, that's not what
the Bible is saying. Symbolic imagery.
Okay.
>> It goes on to say it is a prison. Go
ahead and read that that last part right
there.
>> Uh where does it say it is a prison?
>> Yeah.
>> Um Oh, okay. It is a prison in which
evil powers are confined
and out of which they can at times be
let loose. Oh, interesting. I want you
to notice that because what I'm about to
show you, you're going to see the
relevance to all that. If you go to the
book of Luke 8 26-39, there's a story of
when the when Jesus went out with his
disciples on a boat. And just to give
brief context to what took place the
Bible goes on to say this, and they
arrived at the country of the guanas,
which is over against Galilee. And when
he went forth to land, there met him out
of the city a certain man which had
what? Every I'm think I'm speaking to
the, you know, to the crowd over here. I
was a church this morning. That's why
you see me suited.
>> Yeah. Go ahead.
>> Devils.
>> Okay. So, which had devils a long time.
And we come to find out, remember the
man in chains? Remember, you remember
that story?
>> Yeah. Legion
>> approaching this. Very good. So, they're
approaching this man. Remember this man,
he can't do anything to Jesus because
he's held in check. He gets to the feet
of Jesus and there's dialogue that's
taking place. Now, I want you to
remember the Bible says of a certain man
which had devils how long?
>> A long time.
>> A long time. So, there's a dialogue
taking place with Jesus with this man,
this legion man. And I want you to
notice what the Bible says. And Jesus
asked him, saying, "What is thy name?"
He said, "Legion, because many devils
are were entered into him." Did you
catch that? Yeah,
>> they besought him that he would not
command them to go out into the what?
>> The deep
or the abyss.
>> I want you to that a bit. You before I
even put it up, you already caught on to
it.
>> Abyss.
Revelation 11:7.
>> So, we're talking about spiritual
entities that are taking place. You
follow what I'm saying? Right?
>> In other words, demonic. Listen, this is
demonic forces that are coming up from
hell. if you will from the pits of hell.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. In Revelation 20 verse 1-3 the
Bible also says talking about Satan and
I saw an angel come down from heaven
having the key to the bottomless pit and
a great ch Now this is remember this is
all symbolic imagery okay
>> a chain in his hand and he laid hold on
the dragon
>> and I mean you're not really going to
look for a dragon the dragon I mean the
dragon represents who
>> Satan
>> Satan that old serpent which is the
devil and Satan and bound them a
thousand years and cast him into the
what
>> the bottomless pit
Okay. So, remember we got it. Don't
never forget this. This is all taking
place during the closing of the 1260
years. Did you get what I just said?
>> Yeah.
>> Because it says as they were finishing
their testimony. Remember that? Remember
this text on the
>> on the first part it says and when they
shall have finished their testimony. In
other words, what it's meaning to say
when they are about to close, when
they're about to finish what they were
out there to do, that was the prophesy,
something is happening with this this
time period Clinton close to the year of
1798, something takes place. Now, since
we're locked already locked that
section, let's go to this other point
that we need to understand. This is very
crucial. This will help people that
believe that, oh, these are two literal
people. It's actually Moses and Elijah.
That's not what this is telling us.
Yeah,
>> it's this is symbolic imagery. We're not
looking for two literal people. We
already uncovered by using the
candlesticks, the olive trees is
referring to the new old and new
testament. Am I right?
>> Yeah. Otherwise, we'd be looking for a
harlot on a beast drinking blood and a
woman standing on the moon clothed with
the sun. I mean, there's a lot of
>> actual, right? Actual beast, 10 horn
beast.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. This is you can't you can't. So,
this is symbolic imagery here. There are
some truth and and some elements to it
that may have a um a lit rather there
there may be some literal elements to it
which I have to agree but it's not the
majority of it
>> right
>> now it says here from starting from the
top I want you to read that
>> uh and when they shall have finished
their testimony the beast that ascendeth
out of the bottomless pit shall make war
against them and shall overcome them and
kill them and their dead bodies shall
lie in the street of the great city
which spiritually is called Sodom and
Egypt where also our Lord was crucified.
>> Okay, so this is the other part that we
need to uncover. I want you to notice
the three highlighted areas words
rather. What do what? Repeat them again.
>> So spiritually Sodom and Egypt.
>> So is this literally Sodom and Egypt?
>> No. Spiritually?
>> No. Spiritually, how do we know? Because
it says where our our Lord was what?
>> Oh, where our Lord was crucified. Yeah.
>> Where was Jesus crucified?
>> Good question. Uh, Jerusalem. I'm not
sure.
>> Does that sound like Jerusalem sound
like Sodom and Egypt?
>> No.
>> So, we can't take this literally. You
follow what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> Symbolically, that's all that I'm trying
to establish. Now, spiritually Egypt.
Let's deal with this one first.
Spiritually Egypt. Okay. Now, remember
the story of Moses. Again, we're going
back to the story of Moses. Remember
when Moses showed up on the scene to
Pharaoh? God sent him his brother Aaron.
You remember that story, Mikey?
>> Mhm. Yeah.
>> Okay. I want you to read this. I want
you to read the ne these these two
texts. Go ahead.
>> And afterward Moses told Pharaoh, "Thus
sayeth the Lord God of Israel, let my
people go that they may hold a feast
unto me in the wilderness."
>> Okay.
Go ahead. And Pharaoh said, "Who is the
Lord that I should obey his voice and
let Israel go? I know not the Lord,
neither will I let Israel go."
>> So, I want you to understand what you're
reading because remember it said here
spiritually Egypt. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. He's going here and and Pharaoh
says according to this text, I know not
the Lord.
>> Yes or no?
>> Yeah. I want you to understand
Revelation 11 is trying to tell us.
Something is taking place during the
time period of 1260 year more at the
latter end of that time period. Okay?
That there's a power rising from the
bottomless pit. And this power that is
arising is going against God, but it's
giving you characteristics. And
remember, it's a nation. It's giving you
characteristics of this nation, the
small time period. Okay? We're going to
understand the time period that we're
going to even get into what time period
this is in just a bit. Okay? Now I want
you to understand it says I know not the
Lord. Now I want you to notice Mikey. I
want you to read the next text. This
comes from um Psalms 14:1. Read it.
>> The fool has said in his heart there is
no God. They are called. Okay.
>> A fool has said in his heart there is
>> there's no God.
>> It's very interesting. Years ago I heard
a story. I don't know how true it is or
whatever. I remember heard a story.
There was a man that walked into a
courtyard and it said to the to the
judge, "You know what, judge? I'm sick
of this. He goes, "You know, the
Christians have their holidays. The
Muslims have their holidays, but we
atheists, we don't have our holidays."
And you know what this judge says to
him? He says, "Yes, you do."
>> He says, "Oh, we do." He goes, "Yes, you
got a holiday." He goes, "You got April
Fool's Day."
>> Oh, what do you mean? And he quoted
Psalms 14:1. A fool has said in his
heart, "There is no God."
>> That's awesome.
>> He go, "So, you have a holiday. Go on
with your life." I love it.
>> Okay. All right. So, it's very
interesting that that has Okay. So, now
understanding all this that's taking
place. We understand then what we're
reading here when it says spiritually
Egypt.
We're spiritually Egypt. And you have
this man here that says, "I know not
God." And connect um Psalms 14:1 says,
"The food said has said in his heart,
there is no God." What it's trying to
tell you, whatever power this is that's
rising from the pits of hell is atheism.
Did you get it?
>> Yeah.
>> Revelation 11, it is talking about
atheism.
And now again, so people that never
heard of this um prophecy, they have to
understand this. Now, let's get to the
other section which spiritually is
called what else?
>> Sodom.
>> Okay. So we know that in that nation
atheism will become prominent. The
Bible's also telling us something about
Sodom, a characteristic about Sodom
would also be prominent. Let's talk
about Sodom. Remember Sodom and
Gomorrah?
>> Oh yeah.
>> You had the two angels that came there
to talk to Lot to try to try to get Lot
out. They open the door and who do they
see? They see a crowd of men. Just only
men out there.
>> And what to do with the two angels? The
Bible tells us
>> they were trying to have sex with them.
They were trying to gang rape him.
>> Yeah.
>> To put it very plain and simple.
Remember that?
>> Yep.
>> And remember two angels told him get out
of the city because they were going to
destroy it.
>> Yeah.
>> And from you see that um this man
actually sees the um the cities are
burning.
>> Are are you noticing what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> The Bible says in Jude 1:7, "Even as
Sodom and Gomorrah and the cities about
them in like manner given themselves
over to what? strange flesh. Fornication
and going after strange flesh.
>> Okay. Now remember it says here
spiritually called what again?
>> Sodom.
>> The Bible's telling us what was taking
place in Sodom. It says fornication
going after strange flesh. What do what
do you think it implies when it means
strange flesh
>> or when it says strange flesh? Well, the
Bible talks about not,
you know, men being with men and giving
up the the normal, what's it saying?
Exactly the the normal use of a woman.
>> That was exactly what was taking place
in Sodom.
>> Okay.
>> Let me give you another text here.
Ezekiel 16:49. And I hope that your
audience is is not only watching,
hearing, not only hearing, but also
writing this down because this is how
they're going to give a Bible study. I
do more teaching than preaching. Okay.
>> All right. Behold, this was the iniquity
of thy sister Sodom. What does it say
here? Pride.
>> Pride.
>> Bread and abundance of what? I
>> was in her and in her daughters. I want
you to notice. Neither did she
strengthen the hand of the poor and
needy. I want you to understand the
characteristics that are taking place
during this time period that a a beast,
a nation comes up from the pits of hell,
concocts an idea to make war upon the
word of God.
>> And one of the first characteristics is
that is an atheistical nation. And then
the other characteristic which comes out
of Sodom, we find that it's fornication,
debulery or lwitness. Did you get what
I'm just saying? Or listen
>> the order you want to. So you notice the
characteristics of this nation.
>> Yeah.
>> Now let's identify, let's tackle this
last clause here where spiritually our
Lord was what?
>> Crucified.
>> Our Lord was crucified. Let's look at
Hebrews chapter 6:6. Look at this verse.
For it is impossible for those who were
once enlightened and have tasted of the
heavenly gift and were made partakers of
the Holy Ghost and have tasted the good
word of God and the powers of the world
to come. If they shall fall away and
renew them again unto repentance, the
Bible says, seeing they that what?
>> Crucify to themselves the son of God
aresh and put them into what?
>> Wow.
>> That was in the bottom. And it says
here, seeing they crucify the Lord
themselves, the I mean sorry, they
crucify themselves to the son of God.
The son of God aresh. That means again.
>> Now, can we literally crucify Christ
again? literally put him on on the
cross. No. No.
>> This is symbolic terms,
>> right?
>> That when you and I sin, we s we
spiritually crucify Christ again and put
him into open sin. You know why? Because
he was there to ransom us to save us
from that sin. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> Okay. And if you read in Matthew chapter
25:45, it says here, "Then shall he
answer them, saying, "Verily I say unto
you, in as much as ye did it not to one
the one of the least of these, ye did it
not to what?
>> Not to me."
>> Now this this is symbolic imagery.
Granted,
>> right,
>> terminology, what it's saying is if I
hurt you, I'm actually hurting who?
>> Christ.
>> Okay? Actually hurting Christ. So now we
given all evidence. We understand again
that it was spiritually Egypt which
represents what Mikey
>> atheism
>> and then spiritually Sodom which
represents what Mikey?
>> Fornication, debauchery, lwdness.
>> So we got most of the clues out there.
We can't say this is literal Elijah nor
norm Moses. So we have the question
needs to be asked. What nation arose in
history
could this beast from the bottomless pit
represent that through its legislative
halls, that's the only way that it can
be
>> sanctioned to openly make war against
the word of God and its people for how
many years?
>> Three and a half years.
>> Now, we're going to cover that in just a
bit because we already read it earlier.
>> Now, I want you to watch this video clip
again, not from me. This is History
Channel. I want you to notice, watch
this.
>> More important, it was the revolution
that upset things the most. I mean,
again, when you consider that it got rid
of the Catholic Church, it got rid of
Christianity. It got rid of the
nobility. It got rid of
>> I want you to notice it said the French
Revolution that even got rid of the
Catholic Church.
>> Oo, okay.
>> That's how you understand it was a
hellish doctrine from demons from hell.
Did you get it now?
>> Yeah.
>> You think that the
>> But
>> I was just going to say that means it
excludes the Catholic Church. So,
they're off the table. We're looking at
someone else.
>> Good point. Very good point. They're out
the way. It's something even more
demonic.
>> Now, the Bible doesn't tell us that the
Catholic Church was used by the enemy.
But I want you to understand the Bible I
mean, the enemy doesn't care who he
uses. He's upset and he hates anything
that has to do with God.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Let's let's let's start this from
the top again.
>> More important, it was the revolution
that upset things the most. I mean again
when you consider that it got rid of the
Catholic Church, it got rid of
Christianity. It got rid of the
nobility. It got rid of the king. Got
rid of all these things.
The French Revolution would bring bread
to the poor, democracy to France,
and would establish a whole new order of
society.
But progress would come at a price.
It was really a moment of extraordinary
hope, extraordinary ambition, and then
it turned into this most horrific
tragedy.
>> France is now a constitutional monarchy.
The king forced to share power with the
revolutionaries in the assembly. But it
seems Louis
>> I want you to notice they're talking
about an assembly. Okay.
>> All right.
>> The the the king is not running the show
no more. Okay. They're going to get
ready to oust that. share is growing
smaller by the day as he is forced to
sign law after law diminishing his own
authority and that of the other great
feudal regime the Catholic Church.
>> I want you to notice what church they're
talking about here.
>> Yeah.
>> About to flick inflict a personal wound
on themselves. But check this out. Pay
close attention. Not my words. This is
History Channel. Okay. Check this out.
>> Louis the revolution has hardened Rob
Pierre. Once an impassioned supporter of
a free press, he now reinstates
censorship, a vestage of the old regime.
And with the church already under
attack, Robes Pierre stands idly by as
one of the most radical revolutionaries.
Jacqu Renee Ebe proposes a new agenda,
dechristianization.
>> Did you hear that?
>> Yeah.
>> Out of France, a new agenda. And what is
that?
>> Decchristianization.
to eradicate Christianity.
>> Yeah.
>> From the society.
>> Did you hear that?
>> Now that you see there, they're mocking
even Catholic priests.
>> Now, now Mike, understand this
>> in those times when they saw religion.
Yes, you have Protestants, but
Protestants to them were were little
were little splinters off from the main
church. It was an established church,
right? They really all they saw as
church was a Catholic church.
>> Exactly.
So what the what the history is telling
us that in France they were going to
make a mockery out of this church.
Remember they're going to dechristianize
the nation. Okay. Oh, we're going to get
into this. Get clear into this. After
today's presentation, it's going to be
clear that this is what Revelation 11 is
really talking about.
>> When the crisis go back under attack,
Robes Pierre stands idly by as one of
the most radical revolutionaries. Jacqu
Renee Ael proposes a new agenda,
dchristianization.
When the crisis of the war and internal
rebellion is at its height, people begin
to say the root of all the problem is
priests is religion. And what we've got
to do if we're ever going to be safe
against the enemies revolution is
destroy the power of the Catholic
Church. Superstition, fanaticism, that's
what religion is all about. And
therefore what we have to do is is stamp
out this whole thing entirely. Streets
carrying the word saint are renamed.
Religious icons are destroyed and
replaced with tribute to the new saint
Mar.
The church came to seem simply the enemy
to the radical revolutionaries. Churches
and cathedrals are simply stripped of
their altars. Stained glasses smashed.
Statues are smashed. whose wealth of the
church is simply carted off. Of course,
for European opinion, this was something
even more shocking than the death of the
king.
>> Not even the Christian calendar is
spared.
>> Years are numbered no longer from the
birth of Christ, but from September
1792, the overthrow of the monarchy. It
is now year 1.
Months are named according to the
seasons. July becomes Thermodor. April
Florio
months are broken into three weeks of 10
days each.
>> The revolutionary calendar was certainly
designed as a kind of weapon against
Christianity, against Christian belief.
Of course, by having a 10day week, you'd
no longer have Sundays. So, people
wouldn't even know what day Sunday was
anymore. That
>> Did you hear that, brother?
>> Wow.
>> I want you to understand that's how bad
the devil wanted to get rid of
Christianity. found an outlet and that
was through France. If you think the
Catholic Church were bad, you didn't
when atheism takes the position,
>> you haven't seen yet.
>> This is what was done taking place in in
France.
>> Okay, let me finish this off.
>> It's Christian belief. Of course, by
having a 10day week, you'd no longer
have Sundays. So, people wouldn't even
know what day Sunday was anymore. That's
what they hoped.
The terror spreads across France.
Insurrections are put down with a
vicious, unrelenting cruelty.
In the city of Leon, where
counterrevolutionaries are gaining
ground, the Committee of Public Safety
sets a brutal example.
Hundreds of rebels are tied up, marched
into fields, and mowed down on mass.
A region called the Vond in the west of
France has also become a
counterrevolutionary stronghold.
Rebels and priests are tied together and
packed onto boats that are then
mercilessly sunk.
Up to a 100,000 people are killed in the
vond alone.
In Paris, the blade falls at an ever
more frantic pace.
>> Is that clear?
>> Yeah. That's crazy,
>> Mikey. They were wanted to obliterate
anything that had to deal with Christ.
If you take out Christ completely from
society, you'll have complete anarchy.
Yes or no? Yeah, definitely.
Lawlessness.
>> Lawlessness. You think people can
survive with lawlessness?
>> No way.
>> No, they can't. And I want you to
understand something. How long this is
going to take place. But before I do get
there, I'm going to give you historical
facts, information. Check this out. in
the book I mean in the magazine
Blackwoods magazine dated um 1870 and
I'm quoting France is the only nation in
the world concerning which the authentic
record survives that as a nation she
lifted her hand in open rebellion
against the author of the universe
plenty of blasphemers this doesn't come
from my church okay
>> plenty of blasphemers plenty of infidels
there have been and still continue to be
in England Germany Spain and elsewhere
but France stands is a part in the
world's history as a single state which
by the decree of her legislative
assembly pronounced that there was no
God and of which the entire population
of the capital and a vast majority
elsewhere woman as well as men danced
and sang with joy in accepting the
announcement. Clear? If you look at this
the book called the life of Napoleon uh
Napoleon Bonapart volume one chapter 17
by sir Alan Walter Scott it says the
following intimately connected with
these laws affecting religion that was
from the legislative assembly or the
national convention was that which
reduced the union of marriage. You
notice that the sensiousness remember
that
>> the most sacred engagement which human
beings can form
>> and the preeminence of which leads most
strongly to the consolidation of society
and the state of a mere civil contract
of transis transitory character and
which any two persons might engage in
and cast loose at pleasure. That's what
you have the debriefer if you will.
Okay.
>> Now give you some evidence. We're going
to we're going to revisit this in just
some part when we get into section two
because it's going to get better. But
I'm going to when I'm going to be
talking to our own people, but just a
minute. I want to get this last piece
here which we will more emphasize later
on in today's study.
In Revelation 11:9, it said this about
the two witnesses, the word of God. It
says here, "And they of the people and
kindreds and tongues and nations shall
see their dead bodies, that is the word
of God, the Old and New Testament,
>> three days and a half." Does that sound
like a pro time prophecy to you?
>> Yeah,
>> it does. Right. And shall now suffer the
dead body, be put in the graves. They're
not going to be buried completely and
put away. The Bible's telling us it's
just for a time period. And what is the
time period again?
>> Three and a half days.
>> Okay? So remember, we're using time
prophecy. We got to find you. We got to
find the for um the um the formula too.
Okay. So, right prophetic time prophecy
of three three days and a half. It just
said three days and a half.
>> All right. So, you got one day that
equals what?
>> One year.
>> And then you have three days which will
equal what then?
>> Uh three years. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Three years. But you add a half to
those three years. What do you get?
>> A half a year.
So you get three days and a half which
equals to three and a half.
>> Okay. So then ask we have to ask the
question. So when did these three and
1/2 years take place?
>> Right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Guess what?
This is what we're going to do now
within this time period of 1260 years.
What were the specific years France
ousted the word of God?
>> Now, we're gonna on the evidence to
prove to you when it began and where it
didn't. And Mikey, this is very, very
important because if the Bible's given
us our time prophecy here, we got to
identify exactly the year when it began
and exactly the year when it ended. Yes
or no? Would you agree with that?
>> Yep. Definitely. So remember, as they
were finishing their testimony, as when
they were about to finish,
the beast from the bottomless pit arose
and made war against the Bible. Did we
cover that already?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, Mikey, strap yourself into
your seat because guess what?
>> Now, this is now to section two.
>> I'm gonna speak more to our own people.
>> And I have to do it this way. Now, in
the church that I pertain to, okay,
which I am not ashamed to admit on what
I believe, there's an inspired writer
that says the following. Now, Mikey, I
want you to read what she says.
>> Okay?
>> There's two statements that I'm going to
read. Two quotations I'm going to read.
I want you to read them. Okay? The first
one comes from a book entitled
Testimonies to Minister and Gospel
Workers, page 109. Go ahead.
>> Young men should search the scriptures
for themselves. They are not to feel
that it is sufficient for those older
inexperienced to find out the truth that
the younger ones can accept it from them
as authority. The Jews perished as a
nation because they were drawn from the
truth of the Bible by their rulers,
priests, and elders. Had they heeded the
lessons of Jesus and searched the
scriptures for themselves, they would
not have perished. Amen.
>> Would you agree to that? Yeah,
definitely.
>> Okay. So, even though I'm teaching
people, what is even for you, Mikey?
What or what are you supposed to do?
>> Search for myself and test to make sure
this is true.
>> Don't run with what I'm saying is God.
Oh, he sounded good. He brought the
evidence, so that's good. No, you better
go do your own study.
>> Yeah.
>> It should never be a dove says earnest,
>> right?
>> Never said that. Never. Never let those
words come out your mouth. No, you say,
"Look, here goes the proof. I did my
personal study. This is what I found."
Now, God uses teachers in order to help
that, you know, help you to help
educate.
>> That's what we're doing on this
platform.
>> But I want you to know the Jews perish
as a nation because they were drawn from
the truth of the Bible by their rulers.
In other words, that also happens in my
church, just like any other church. We
tend to believe what they say. And when
we hear something long enough, it
becomes gospel. Yes or no?
>> Yep. That's true.
>> And sometimes we don't get verified. We
just think, "Oh, why would our leaders
lie about it? This is what they said.
This is what it I'm telling you. I'm
saying that for a reason because where
I'm going to go to the point that I'm
going to go to really really real soon
today is that's I believe that is the
issue that is also happening until the
identification of who that king of the
south is.
>> Yeah.
>> Setting it up. Now I want you to read
the next quote. I think the next quote
is even more important than this one.
Read the next one.
>> Search the scriptures for in them you
think that you have eternal life. Every
position of truth taken by our people
will bear the criticism of the greatest
minds. The highest of the world's great
men will be brought in contact with
truth and therefore every position we
take should be critically examined and
tested by the scriptures. Now we seem to
be unnoticed. But this will not always
be. Movements are at work to bring us to
the to the front. And if our theories of
truth can be picked to pieces by
historians or the world's greatest men,
it will be done. Wow.
>> Did you catch that?
>> Yeah.
>> In other words, you see how I'm razoring
in
>> Yeah.
>> on these studies study. You see how fine
tooth I'm combing everything
>> with fine with a fine comb.
>> Why? Because I've always believed in
this statement.
>> Amen. Many of us run with just because
our pastors or even theologians said it
and we think, well, this has to be the
truth,
>> right?
>> Well, I'm adding this statement because
this is also going to apply to the
identity of who's the king of the south.
I'm Yeah, king of the south. Remember it
says here, movements are at work to
bring us to the front. I mean, there are
people that are hearing us say, "Oh, you
guys are saying this, any church for
that matter, and we're not exempted.
believe that this prophecy or you're
saying that this this prophecy means
this. Okay, we're setting it up. In
other words, are at work getting ready
to challenge us on these points. And she
goes to say, "And if our theories of
truth can be picked to pieces by
historians of the world's greatest men,
>> it will."
>> Yeah.
>> This is why I believe I had to do my own
personal study. Yes. I love that was
handed to me by by the leaders and by
our church. But guess what? I have to
also study for myself.
>> Amen, brother.
>> I don't This person said this person I
don't do that.
>> Yeah.
>> Pick to piece. This is very important
for what we're going to get into now.
Okay. Let's get into the study.
We already talked about I already I
already put it on the platform and I
just explained to you something that has
to deal with
um Revelation 11. But before we even get
there, let's go back to the book of
Daniel. In the book of Daniel, it says
the following. In Daniel 12:4, the Bible
says, "But thou, O Daniel," oh, read it.
Go ahead and read it, Brother Mikey.
>> But thou, oh Daniel, shut up the words
and seal the book even to the time of
the end. Many shall run to and fro, and
knowledge shall be increased.
>> Okay? So many shall run. In other words,
the increase of spiritual or even
biblical knowledge as well as issue I
mean uh uh knowledge in the world is
going to increase. Yes or no?
>> Yep.
>> Yes. On that latter end we know that
when it comes to like boats, planes,
automobiles in the last days have it in
has it increased?
>> Oh definitely. Yeah.
>> But the Bible's not really talking about
that. The context of the Bible is
talking about the word of God more is
going to understand. And what time
period? What did it say there? uh in the
time of the end.
>> Okay, so that's going to be our focus of
attention because our church uses this
this statement to try to say that it's
something. We'll get to that in just a
bit. That the king of the north, the
identity of the king of the north is
something. It's an ideology. Okay, we'll
get to that in just a bit. Now, when did
the t time of the end begin? Now, in our
church, that inspired writer, her name
is Ellen White, said the following. I
want you to notice.
>> Don't miss this. Oh, and by the way, I
want you to start getting a piece of
paper and a pencil out there because I'm
gonna have you write something down just
in in just a bit. Okay. All right. Now,
in the book, The Great Controversy, page
355, she says the following. But since
1798, the book of Daniel has been what?
>> Unsealed.
>> Unsealed. Knowledge of the prophecies
have increased, and many have proclaimed
the solemn message of the judgment near.
Now, that's what she said. And what year
did she just say this um that the that
the book of Daniel was unsealed?
>> 1798.
>> 1798. Now people would say, "No, that's
what you guys say or the the the church
of denomination that this woman is
affiliated." Well, it was very
interesting. I had the privilege of
going to Google and I just typed it in
and you can see from the top I said
verses in the Bible that prophesy the
third. No, I'm sorry. I got the wrong
one. I I included this one. I didn't
mean that. All right. This is what I
meant. I don't know why I stuck that one
in there. According to Daniel 11:40, you
see it on the top in the search bar. It
says here, according to Daniel 11:40, in
what year did the time of the end begin?
Now, I just simply stated that I just
wanted to see what Google had to say.
And it says the following. Go ahead,
read. Can you read that right there on
my
>> Yeah. According to many prophetic
interpretations, particularly within
Adventist theology, the time of the end
mentioned in Daniel 11:40, began in
1798.
not there. I want you to notice I want
you to notice it says according to many
prophetic interpretations, right?
>> But then they single out Adventist. So
it's not just Adventist alone. Did you
guys
>> Yeah.
>> And when did the time of the end begin?
>> 1798.
>> Not my words, that's Google.
>> Continue to read.
>> Uh this date marks the conclusion of the
1260year
prophecy mentioned in Daniel 7:25.
co coinciding with Napoleon's general
berier removing the pope pious
whatever number that is what is it
>> 56
>> from Rome signaling the end of the papal
political power
>> did you catch that so they gave you here
yes or no
>> under that underneath that it's a key
interpretations regarding this timeline
include I want you to read that what
does it say under underneath that
>> uh 1798 start the time of the and is
generally understood to extend from 1798
to the second coming of Jesus.
>> This is what Google is saying.
>> Yeah, this is interesting.
>> Google not my words. Okay, I can give
you some other examples but for the sake
of time, let me move forward. So now
let's keep this in mind. the issue that
some people from our church believe
about it. Um, let me take let let me
take you to the text in Daniel 11:40 so
everybody can understand be on the same
page. It says the following. And at the
time of the end, what time did that
begin?
>> 1798.
>> Okay, I want you to understand she said
it began.
She never uses this text to say that
this verse is referring to that same new
year. That's not what it's saying here.
It just began. And from 1798, some
events are going to follow. Does that
make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Shall the king of the south push
at him and the king of the north shall
come against him like a whirlwind with
chariots and with horsemen and with many
ships. Now many people even outside of
my church will also many people not
everybody will agree that the king of
north is the papacy. We established that
didn't we in our last presentation.
>> Okay. But the issue now comes and the
fork of the road if you will is the
identity of the king of the south at
this time period. What year is this
again?
>> 179.
>> What time period?
>> Yeah. After 178.
>> Okay. So now we got to establish I'm
going to hammer a certain point. So you
please you've got to follow me. Okay.
>> Matter of fact, let's offer another word
of prayer. Let me offer another word of
prayer. Father in heaven, as we're
getting ready to um to to to to
talk on this particular part of the
subject, we need more wisdom. Those that
are watching or those that will be
watching, we're asking Lord that in the
name of Jesus, you will eradicate the
enemy. If I am preaching falsehood, it's
going to be made clear here today. But
if there is truth to this, may your name
be glorified. Not me. I am nobody. I'm
just a tool. I'm just a messenger. But
please father help me to explain this as
you will want everyone else to
understand it. Help me to use tac and
wisdom as I do so. And may your name be
glorified at the end. In Jesus name we
pray. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Okay. Now question. When did we say the
time of the end began again?
>> Began at 1798.
>> Okay. So it was 1798. So let's revisit
just briefly Revelation 11. We got to go
back there because that's where a lot of
the people from our church like to tie
in this aspect of what happened in
France. Let's get into it just real
quick. And we're just going to briefly
briefly grace through all this. The
Bible says here in Revelation 11:2, "And
I will give power unto my two witnesses
and they shall prophesy for how long
again?" Um, Brother Mikey,
>> uh, 1,23
score days. 1260 years, right?
>> 1260 years, right?
>> Mhm. Okay. Now, who are these two
witnesses again?
>> Uh, the Old and the New Testament.
>> Very good. Remember, we confirmed it
with Zechariah chapter 4. Remember that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, now we already covered that.
There's no need to really get into that
um um further. Okay. But let's get into
this verse um these words because we got
it. Let's just um reread it so we can
get some context to why I'm bringing all
these points. The Bible says here, "When
they have finished their testimony, that
is the word of God." Okay? The beast
that ascended out of the bottom of this
pit shall make war against them, and
shall overcome them and kill them, and
that their body shall lie in the street
of the great city, which spiritually is
called Sodom and Egypt, where our Lord
or also our Lord who's crucified. And it
goes on to say, "And they of the people
and kindreds and tongues and nations
shall see their bodies 3 days and a
half.
And after 3 days and a half. So they're
going to be dead lying for how long,
Mikey?
>> Um 3 and 1/2 days,
>> which is equal to
>> 3 and 1/2 years.
>> Okay. And then after three and a half
years, the Bible tells us after that
time period and a half that the spirit
of life from God entered into them and
they stood up on their feet and great
fear fell upon them which saw them. Now
remember, they weren't put into graves.
So what the Bible is trying to say is it
was only temporary.
>> So what happened in France is only going
to be a temporary ordeal. As hellish as
it was, it was only being temporary.
Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, it does.
>> Okay. What nation took the pope out of
office in 1798? Do you remember that?
>> General Berier.
>> I'm throwing something else.
>> What nation?
>> Yeah, French, right?
>> It was the French. Now, for those that
don't know, we we just we're going to
now remember we read this earlier.
Remember what Google said here?
>> It said here on the bottom the bottom of
the top of the paragraph, it says
coinciding with Napoleon's general birth
year removing Pope Pas the 6th from
Rome. And what year did that happen?
>> 1798.
>> That happened in 1798. Okay. So, that
was France that took out the pope in
1798. Even Google said it, right? Okay.
Right. Now, let's go back this inspired
writer. I want you to listen to what she
says in in a book that she writes. And
everybody, those that are hearing about
this book here, the great controversy,
those that are your followers, please
get a copy of this book. If you want to
get a copy with this book, get with
Mikey. Um, send a message to him, email
him, get with me, and I'll get this book
out to you. You guys,
>> you give them out free. I give them out
free, too. So, just get with us. And
this is a wonderful powerful book to
help you to read between the lines what
the Bible is already saying. Okay. Now
I'm quoting page 266. It says here the
periods here mentioned 42 months and
1,23 score days are the same alike
representing the time in which the
church of Christ was to suffer
oppression from Rome. The 1260 years of
papal supremacy began in AD 538 and
would therefore terminate in what year?
Mikey?
uh 1798
>> and at that time what does it say now?
>> Uh French army entered Rome.
I want you to notice something that she
is saying here because this is where a
lot of people or proponents from the
church that I belong to are trying to
inject what she's not saying. I want you
to notice even though the chapter is
talking about what happened in France in
1798 she says something that many people
think that she's saying that she's not
saying
>> she says here at that time France the
French army a French army entered into
Rome I want you to know she doesn't say
atheism entered into Rome she says what
>> French army
>> now people were earnest it was atheism
you just proved that it was yes I did
but we're reading something that is not
here. Let me go on. I'm going to prove
my point in just a bit. And made the
pope a prisoner and he died in exile.
Though a new pope was soon afterward
elected, the papal hierarchy has never
since been able to wield the power which
it before possessed. During that time
period, they lost their remember church
and state was analled. Okay,
>> continuing on. On page 439, this is what
she says. This period as stated in
preceding chapters began with the
supremacy of the papacy
AD 538 and terminated in what year
again?
>> 1798.
>> Okay. At that time the pope was made
captive by the French ar. See she's
repeating herself.
>> Another section. The papal power
received a his deadly wound and the
prediction was fulfilled. He that leadth
in captivity shall go into captivity.
Continuing on on pages 269 and 27, she
says the following. According to the
words of the prophet, now I want you to
notice because this is what I emphasized
on heavily when we were dealing with the
two witnesses in the time period that
they were going to prophesy in
sackcloth. According to the words of the
prophet, then a little before 1798, some
power of satanic origin and character
would rise to make war upon the Bible.
And in the land where the testimony of
God's two witnesses should be thus
silenced, there will be manifest an
atheism of the pharaoh and the the
lentiousness of Sodom. Did we already
prove that?
>> Wow. Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, you notice I didn't use her
writings to prove it though,
>> right?
>> Amen.
>> Okay. Now, I'm just here's just for
those that want to get more context and
more understand. Even even this woman
even believed it. I believe she was a
inspired writer. Check this out.
This prophecy had received its most
exact and striking fulfillment in the
history of what nation?
>> Um, France.
>> Continue to read Mikey what she says
here
>> where it says during the revolution.
>> Yes. Go ahead. During the revolution in
1793, the world for the first time heard
an assembly of men born and educated in
civilization and assuming the right to
govern one of the finest of the European
nations, uplift their united voice to
deny the most solemn truth which man's
soul receives, and renounce unanimously
the belief and worship of a deity, Sir
Walter Scott, life of Napoleon.
You know what she's doing? She's
actually quoting from this man here. So,
she was also looking to the history. Yes
or no?
>> Yeah.
>> She's looking really at that same
history. So, we're not off.
>> Not on point with this. Okay.
>> Now, let's read this next quote. Go
ahead, read this.
>> France is the only nation in the world
concerning which the authentic record
survives, that as a nation, she lifted
her hand in open rebellion against the
author of the universe. plenty of
blasphemer. Okay,
>> so you notice she's quoting from also
another magazine that I just posted to
you earlier. She's quoting from this
one,
>> right?
>> Remember that? Black magazine.
>> Yeah.
>> France is the only nation in the world
concerning which the authentic records
survive. She's she's she's repeating it.
So she's doing her study. Yes or no?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So let's finish. I want you to
notice what she says. Go ahead. continue
to read from plenty of blasphemers.
>> Plenty of blasphemers, plenty of
infidels. There have been and still
continue to be in England, Germany,
Spain, and elsewhere. But France stands
apart in the world's history as the
single state which by the decree of her
legislative assembly pronounced that
there was no God and of which the entire
population of the capital and a vast
majority elsewhere. Women as well as men
danced and sang with joy accepting the
announcement. Black Blackwoods magazine
November 1870.
According to what you read, Mikey, which
body made that law? Which body?
>> Uh,
>> it says it there.
>> I see.
>> I see highlight.
>> What you read? It says the decree of her
what?
>> France.
>> It was a highlight. It says the decree
of her legislative assembly. The thing
that is underlined.
So I want you to understand this was the
governing body that made the laws
>> legislate about this. Right.
>> Right.
>> Now it was that decree from that body
that brought in that law that was going
to oust the word of God. We already saw
the um the um the the um the History
Channel clip. Remember that?
>> Right.
>> This is what Blackwoods magazine
actually goes on to say. So they know
they know this was in 1870.
>> Wow.
>> Right. They said the decree from the
legislative assembly. Now another point
that I want to stress that this woman
actually says in that same book it reads
as the following. The speaking of the
nation is through that is is the action
of his what?
>> Legislative and judicial authorities.
>> Legislative makes the laws or judicial
interprets the laws. Yes or no?
>> Right. Yeah.
>> Yes. No. all of this was happening and I
want you to understand when this
actually happened. It happened in the
year of 1793.
>> I want you to take your paper and on the
left side of your paper all the way at
the left side of your paper. Okay? If
you have a paper, okay, what you're
going to do is you're going to take your
paper. Don't don't mind this here. But
you're going to put your that that that
1793 over here. Okay? Put it somewhere
here. 1793. Okay? All
right. Now, that's the year 1793 when
this all took place. And I'm going to
prove that to you right now. But
watch, you're going to see this. Okay?
>> Christianity and the French Revolution.
Not my words. This is Alfonso allergy.
I have it in my possession. Okay? So,
I'm not just out of, you know, out of
nowhere. Okay? It says here, and I'm
quoting, the establishment of the
Republican era, that is the substitution
of the Republican calendar for the
Gregorian. Remember we went by the
Gregorian but remember they ousted it
>> right
>> instead of seven days to 10 days.
Remember that?
>> Yep.
>> The 5th October 7. What year does he
give us?
>> 1793.
>> My words, his words.
>> Yeah.
>> Was a political move but it was also
anti-religious. Did you hear what he
said?
>> Yeah.
>> As appears from the reports of Fabay and
I'm not going to read it which are full
of philosophic attacks against dogma. He
goes on to say to substitute other dates
and other festivals for the usual ones
to abolish what it now
>> to abolish Sunday and substitute the
10th day.
>> Isn't that what isn't that what um
History Channel already stated?
>> Yep.
>> To replace the names of the saints by
those of objects which constitute true
national wealth was to tear from
Catholicism a part of its adorance and
pre. Now, if it's atheistical, that's
what they're coming to do. They're
taking away religion. Did you get it?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, is that clear? I cannot
overemphasize on this point because it's
going to be key is going to be key to
later on to a point that I'm going to
make later on. So, you notice because
atheism is now sanctioned and governed
and made by law to eradicate
eradicate Christianity,
>> right,
>> from from what you call it? From France.
It says that they were going to take
everything out and as a result that's
what makes it atheism. Would you agree?
>> Yeah. Yeah. When you get rid of religion
altogether atheism.
>> Correct. Correct. And of its adorance
and prestige. Nay to drive it violently
out of the ordinary lives of the nation.
This decree remember by the legislative
assembly horrified foreigners. That
means even people from other nations
said what?
>> Whoa.
>> The world is ousting God. Are you crazy?
It sent a shock wave in the western
world.
>> They brought they thought that France
had already what? Destroyed Christianity
within its borders. They thought it was
completely done and over with.
>> This book here, the rights of man, the
rights of terror. I have this book in my
procession. This is what I found when
I'm studying myself. I'm doing my own
study because I got to confirm if that's
what the Bible says, then I want to I
want to get the documentation for it.
Check this out.
>> Yeah.
>> Look, I want you to know and I'm
quoting. What does it say on the top
right there?
>> Decchristianization.
>> So that's the point that they're going
to get ready to talk about
>> today. Students studying the French
Revolution learned that the convention
voted to abolish monarchy and founded
the first republic on September 22nd.
And what year?
>> 1793.
>> We're establishing a date,
>> brother Mikey. We have to establish a
date. Remember it was three and a half
years. Remember that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. You put that date on your on your
on your paper. Right.
>> Right. 1793.
>> Okay. Check this out. Back then,
however, the date was referred to
vendor. That's French. I don't speak
French. I speak Spanish. I France was
the was on the threshold of a new era
and the committee wanted a completely
new calendar. Did we talk about it
already?
>> We did.
>> 10 day that began numbering years from
the date of the monarchy was done away
with and that created all new months,
weeks, and days. The new revolutionary
calendar was most notably not based on
Christianity. Time was no longer counted
from the year of Jesus's birth. New
10day weeks completely did away with
Sundays.
>> I want you what I'm hear what I'm
reading to you here. I didn't get this
from my church. This is my own personal
study. This is the long homework. I mean
it was it was for years. I had to look
and find information. Okay. Continuing
on. It goes on to say, "The new calendar
was was spearheaded of a was the
spearhead, I'm sorry, of a growing
movement of what again?
A movement of dchristianization."
>> Very good. As the nation embarked on its
new most radical phase, people believed
that Christianity had to be done away
with placed by devotion to the state.
>> Sometime people had already been turning
away from the church. Many has ceased
going to mass. places named after saints
have been given new name new I'm sorry
given new revolutionary titles but in
September what year again
>> 1793
>> this trend became a movement I want you
to notice not my words their words so
let me just read from the top it says
here from Paris decristianization
quickly spread across the nation now now
brother Mikey the reason why I want to
emphasize that because it starts off in
what city of France
>> what city of France Paris
>> Paris That's the hub, right? That's
where
>> legislate the legislative body goes,
right? From it starts from there and it
permeates to the nation of of of France.
Yes or no?
>> Yes.
>> So, it starts there and it will also end
there. What do you think?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. In most of the major town,
cathedrals were stripped of their
valuables and converted into temples of
reason. Many other churches were simply
closed. Priest resigned their offices
and married. Check that out. Even the
priest. But remember, they're lower
things. Non-Christian revolutionary
names for babies became popular. Indeed,
the new government's aim of replacing
religion with the worship worshipful
devotion to the state appeared to be
succeeding.
>> Wow.
>> The suppression of Christianity was just
one sign of change under the first
republic. The Christianization
accompanied the infamous period of new
revolutionary justice known as the what?
>> Known as terror.
>> Terror. Wow. as the terror. Okay, now
listen to what it says here. Now this
one comes from a concise history of the
ro of the Catholic Church. Not my words,
their words. Check this out. The first
move in the decristianization was the
adoption of the Republican cander
calendar on October 7th. And what year
again?
>> 1793.
>> Out of the mouth of two three two to
three witnesses, let every word be
established. Right? Amen. So I'm giving
places that they're citing the same year
that this all took place. So we're
establishing that anchor point within
the year frame. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> And designed to remove all messages of
Christianity.
>> The Gregorian calendar was discarded.
That's the calendar you and I still use
today.
>> The Christian Sunday and the 7-day week
were suppressed and the 10day week was
put into in its place. We already read
all this. Now listen to this. All
religious holidays were cancelled
>> and all of the birth of Christ was
dropped by establishing a new era. And
then it finishes off by saying this. The
second move to dischristianize net
France began in the provinces under
agents of the agents of the national
convention. Now this is the body.
Remember this is the legislative body.
It was the legislative body as well as
the national con convention or the I'm
sorry the legislative assembly and the
national convention as well.
One of these fanatical bloodthirsty
ex-priests named Foche opened up the
dechristianization campaign. Hey, a a
decistization
campaign in the church on September
22nd. What year again?
>> 1793.
>> Okay. So, check this out. So, we
established the first year when it
began. Yes or no?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So, according to prophecy, what
would happen after three and a half
years?
>> They would rise back up. Very good.
Let's look at what this writer was
saying in the book Great Controversy.
God's faithful witnesses slain by the
blasphemous power that ascended out of
the bottomless pit were not long to
remain silent. After three days and a
half, the spirit of life I'm sorry.
Yeah. The spirit of life of God from God
entered into them and they stood from I
mean sorry they stood upon their feet
and great fear fell upon them all which
I'm adding words fell upon them which
saw them. Revelation 11:11. So, she
quotes what we just read earlier. Now,
follow me. I want you to notice what she
says next. Listen to this. Don't miss
this.
>> In what year?
>> 1793.
>> The decrees which abolished Christian
religion and set aside the Bible passed
the what?
>> Past
the French assembly.
>> Okay. Now, listen to what is key to read
what she says next. these I mean I'm
sorry three years and a half later
>> a resolution rescending these decrees
thus granting toleration for the
scriptures was adopted by the what
>> by the
>> it's in red I mean highlighted
>> the same body
>> okay so she says here and I want you I
want you to pay close attention Mike
because this is going to get fascinating
check this out it says here in the year
1793 Three, the French assembly ousted
the scriptures, right?
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. Three and a half years later, that
same body, the one that put it into law
to the scriptures, is the same body
three and a half years later to bring it
back. Is that not right? Is that what
I'm reading?
>> Yeah,
>> that's what I'm reading, right? Is that
what you're reading?
>> Yeah, we're reading. And then she goes
on to say, "The world stood a gas at the
enormity of guilt which had resulted
from a rejection of the sacred oracles
and men recognized the what?" I want you
to read the following. Recognize the
what?
>> Recognize the I'm just losing place
where you're at. Men recognize the
necess the necessity of faith in God and
his word as the foundation of virtue and
morality. Wow.
In other words, what she is saying is
when they ousted the scriptures and they
s they soon immediately saw the result
of what what was going what was taking
place. They said, "What have we done?"
Did you get it?
>> Yeah.
>> Now, in what year did we read that it
all began again?
>> 1793.
>> Okay. You got 1793, right? You look at
your paper, right?
>> How many years did the did the two
witnesses lay on the streets dead for?
three and a half years.
>> Okay. So now I want you to take your
paper and those that are there those
those that are watching
you can take a paper too. You can do
this simple exercise. It's easy math. I
want you to take your paper Mikey and
write down 1793. Okay. Write down 179
>> 1793. Let me see if I can get a pen
over. I don't even think I got a pen
here.
>> Oh yeah, I do have.
>> Okay. I want you to write down 1793.
Okay? So, you're going to write down
on one part. I can write it down here.
You got 1793.
So, that's what you will have. You will
put it down something like that. You see
how I have it here on the screen?
>> I see it.
>> Okay. Now, I want you to count three
years from 1793. So, the first year,
year one, will be to what year?
>> 94.
>> 1794. Right. The next year, year two,
will make it to what?
>> 1795.
Third year will make it to what?
>> 1796.
>> 1796. I want you to notice three and a
half years. So, let's just say the half
because you can't go a complete full
year. So, let's say the half will take
you to what year?
>> 17 possibly. Um, it's in the way there.
1797.
1797,
right?
>> That's what you have on your paper,
>> Yeah.
>> Let's look on the screen for those that
probably don't have the ability to do
what you um doing and you you and I
doing so that they can see it as it's on
their screen.
>> You got 1793 right now. What we're going
to do is we're going to have to add the
three and a half years. Remember the
French the France legislates to outlaw
the Bible in what year again, Mikey?
>> 1793.
>> Okay. So we have three and a half years
that the prophecy has given us that this
was going to last for. First year takes
us to 1794 which you got correct. The
second year took us to 1795 which you
got correct. And the third year took us
to 1796. Yes or no?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So now remember it happened in the
fall.
So that would mean then if it's half a
year it's not going to take you to a
whole full year in the fall. It's going
to have to take you into the spring. Yes
or no?
>> Right.
>> But of what year? Spring of 1797.
>> 1797. I want you to notice, please,
those that are watching, pay close
attention.
So, we're getting 1797. Prophecy
predicted. She gave us an anchor point
of a date. 1798. I want you to listen to
what we're going to read following.
Check this out.
If we may judge by Paris, the Roman
church after the establishment of the
separation was very flourishing and it
is in it is for Paris that we have most
information at the Easter festival of
April and what year?
>> Um 1797. Wow.
>> Series were held in 50 chapels of
churches where
>> in Paris exactly started. You
understand? I want you to notice the
date where in Paris, remember the same
body or the same city that ousted
religion. I want you to notice what's
taking in Paris. What's going on in
Paris?
>> They're bringing back 50 churches.
>> So, does that look like they're out
they're continuing to ou religion in
that year?
>> No, it's over. It's reviving.
>> Didn't that lady that lady that people
probably call crazy? They don't know.
She doesn't know what she's talking
about. Didn't she say that three and a
half years later, as the Bible already
predicted it, that that same body was
going to bring back religion?
>> Yep. Wow.
>> And what year did this happen?
>> 1797.
>> Okay, let's continue to read on. He goes
on to say, "By the pip papistical
clergy, that's the Roman Catholic
Church, had full liberty to do what?"
>> Celebrate their worship.
>> Hold up. I thought I I I I thought they
ided it completely. But this is in 1796
>> with large congregations in the eight
churches. Both the Protestants and Jews
submitted to the laws and silently
enjoyed the liberty accorded them after
centuries of persecution.
>> Wow.
>> The government remember the national
convention and the legislative assembly
seems to have had no need to trouble
about any any of them.
>> Leave them alone. Don't believe
>> Wow.
Check this one out. This comes from the
book Religion and the Reign of Terror
and the Church During the French
Revolution. Not my words. These are the
historians's words. Check this out. The
National Councils
>> which assembled and Paris in what year?
>> 1797.
>> They also came back since 1801. But I'm
not worried about the latter date. I'm
working I'm worried about the former
date. That's my concern right now.
>> More respectable assemblies were never
held in Christendom. But that's
interesting. Something significant
happened with these two council
meetings. They were not made up of o
opalent prelades. It was at the price of
the severe sacrifices that most of the
members made the journey because of
their unconquerable attachment to the
faith of their what?
>> Forefathers. Wow.
>> In other words, you know what it's
saying? In 1797, people said, "No, we
got to go because of what we used to
believe in. This is something we got to
do."
>> Wow.
Though it was not our business to write
the history of these two councils, we
may however, the writer says here, refer
to the results. It was first convoked,
now I have italicized for the lay people
that don't understand these these simple
words. It means summoned at Paris by
bishops by who? Who? Bishops who
>> in 1797
>> it looks like bishops are having words
they haven't say so
>> and had preceded by regular elections in
the provincial senots that's the
assembly of the clergy it was open and
those are that's my italicized words
that's with the emphasis added by me
okay it was open in August by reason of
uh by sermon I'm All right. By loos. The
pious bishop expressed his what? Every
his what?
>> His joy at the spectacle of the reader.
>> Recently prescribed religion rising like
Christ from its tomb. Wow.
>> Didn't the Bible said it looked like
they were dead?
>> Yeah.
>> But the bishops are saying we're seeing
it come back. What year was that?
>> Uh it came back in 1797.
That's what they're saying. At least
this is what he's writing at least in
that year. But it gets even deeper than
that. Who of you said he would have
dared to indulge in the faintest
expectation that is in a little time one
would in a little time that in a little
time one would see united in this holy
place these vulnerable um venerable
bishops these pious pastors all these
intrepid priests who lately the victims
of a violent tempest remember what
happened during this reign of terror
>> in the of a most horrible pro
prescription were wandering from cavern
to remember they were out they were
exiled
Okay. And then it goes on to say this.
Or pining in dark and sickly prisons and
weeping not over their captivity, not
over the burning of their chains, but
over the desolation, I'm sorry,
desolating sessation of what?
>> Worship.
>> Mikey, notice what it says here. Or
pining in dark and sickly pum prisons
and weeping. Didn't we talk about
sackloth?
>> Yeah. Oh wow.
>> Why? because of religion, because the
word of God, it was ousted.
>> And they're not even quoting the Bible
here. Then painting the joy that had
been manifested throughout the country
on the revival of what?
>> Worship.
>> He closed with a touching exert
exhortation to harmonious action
addressed to the refractory clergy.
>> He goes on to say, "Finish off here.
Check this out. Among the first acts of
the council, remember the body, the
legisl legislative council convention
>> was the sending of two letters. One to
the who?
>> Pope.
>> I want you to know and it's coming from
where? What nation?
>> Uh Paris. Is it France?
>> France. France, right? It's sending a
letter. I want you to notice because I'm
setting everybody up to take my claim
later on. Okay. Mhm.
>> France
>> in 1798 is dispatching a letter to the
pope and the other to the non-jury
clergy urging both of the necessity of
consilitary cooper cooperation. It
showed itself very moderate in its
measures and generously liberal toward
all its opponents. It desired to
introduce what? Prayers in the v in in
the reorganized church.
>> Wow. and took stringent measures for
introducing and securing strict morals
both in the clergy and in the
membership. Now, what I'm going to do
here, I'm going to take you back to the
book called the concise history of the
of the Catholic Church. Here, this page
deChristianization itself has spent its
force by what year?
>> 1794.
>> I want you to notice because many people
will gloss over this. You know what this
book is trying to tell us? that though
it started off in the by the by the um
I'm sorry by the year of 1792 remember
the prophecy began at 1793
>> correct
>> it only took a year up to a year that
they started to see what is happening in
society as a reason for house and
religion
>> wow
>> the very next year it has spent this
force and with the decree of February 21
1795 two years later which guaranteed
the free exercise of any religion there
was a rush to open the what
>> churches again. Wow.
>> What you
>> 1794
was
>> even though the legislative assembly
enacted a law to ou religion thus making
them um atheistic what we're right what
we're hearing from history is that
within a year's time they remember she
says that they were a gas of what they
saw.
>> So
>> it started to move in with grassroot
movements. Okay. Eventually it's going
to pop up to the 1793. So the
legislative body makes this law but you
know what people see no we got to start
bringing it back. So slowly and
gradually it's coming right back. There
was a rush to open the churches again
and the very point of revival the re re
the revolution struck at the person of
the pope himself.
>> Wow.
>> That was very interesting. This man here
George Cwley writing of the apocalypse
of John St. John he gives us two dates
himself. Not my words his words. Check
this out and I'm quoting. The church in
the Bible had been slain in France on
from November 1793 to June 1797. Did you
catch that?
>> Yeah. Wow.
>> The three years and a half were expended
and the Bible so long and so sternly
repressed before was placed in honor and
was openly the book of free what?
>> Protestantism.
>> Whoa. I want you to know,
>> you notice on on your paper and what I
put up on the calendar, you got 1793 to
1797. Yes or no?
>> Yep. Three and a half years.
>> I want you to notice my next question.
What system? Not nation. We're not
talking about the nation. I'm talking
about the system or the ideology.
Do some say took the pope out of office
in 1798?
>> Uh, atheism.
>> Atheism. Right. Okay. If that is the
case, I need you to help me out there,
Mikey. Let's look back at this table.
1793,
1794 makes one year. 1795 makes another
year. 1793 when 1796 makes three years.
And you add another half, it only takes
us to 1797.
>> Right?
>> My question is, where do we get atheism
from in 1798?
If the Bible gave three and a half
years, it can go no further than 1797.
Remember, at the time of the end, France
was the nation that took out the pope of
Rome. We're going to establish that
point because what she did not say was
atheism took him out. There's a reason
for that.
>> I'm going to highlight on that point.
>> This is where we're missing it and we're
saying she's saying something that she's
not saying
>> because we already knew that religion
was getting reestablished.
The body that's ousted it is the same
Biden that brought it back. Rescended
she uses in what year? 1797. So how is
it that France then is the atheistical
power that takes out Fr. um
>> the people the proponents of that notion
will say well Ernest it was atheist. If
it was France they were atheistical.
What are you trying to say? I'm trying
to tell you is it wasn't atheist and I
took it out. So that begs us to ask a
question. Then what was the motive then
behind it? M
>> oh they were going to religion. That's
what I thought when I came into the
church because other people were telling
me that.
>> Don't some people say that atheism took
out the pope of Rome in 1798? Yes. Now
according to history however what was
the real reason why the French occupied
Rome in Italy or Rome Italy. This is
where we need to get into the meat of
the subject. And and Mikey if there's
anything you need to pay close attention
to it is it is this. And your viewers
need to watch and listen and pay close
attention and take notes and do your own
homework. Don't take it from me. I'm
just I'm just a
>> I'm going to take you to a man by the
name of Richard Dupa. 1770 to 1831 he
lived. Now he was a ring English writer,
a lawyer and a drossman. And in I want
you to know is read the rest of it.
um and an eyewitness of the French
occupation and the sub subversion of the
papal government in Rome in the year
1798.
>> Okay. So he says here that he was an
eyewitness to the account of when Berier
shot to um France I mean shot to Rome
and ousted the pope. Did you get it?
>> Yeah.
>> He was an eyewitness. He writes that
account in this book called the brief
account of the subversion of the papal
government in 1798.
I would advise you get this copy. I got
it right here. You get this copy and
those those viewers get this copy. This
is fact reproduction of the events that
he actually saw and he jotted down.
>> Wow.
>> This is not a make story, but some
historian that came in years later. No,
no, no, no. He saw exactly what took
what took place. This is a key book that
everybody should have. those that are
watching and those of you that probably
still oppose this view, you need to get
that book because you're either going to
go by the history account or you're
going to go by something that had never
actually took place. You be the one to
decide.
>> Now, I'm going to read the following and
I'm quoting from him. Check what he has
to say. He's going to give you reasons
of what took place. An hour or two
before it was dark in the afternoon of
the 27th December of 1797. What year did
he give?
>> 1797.
before 1798. In other words, before the
arrival of Berier, a year before
something is taking place. Now, we got
to understand why France or why Bonapart
Napoleon dispatched Berthier to Rome.
Many people at least from proponent from
my side of the coin will say, "Oh,
because atheism was about to stamp out
Christianity because it was a Christian
church."
>> H
>> well, let's we can prove that through
history if that's the case. This is an
eyewitness. Some persons began to
assemble together in the Lgera.
Now, he's given us an account of
something that took place in 1797. Has
nothing to do with Napoleon directly.
Okay? He's talking about an event. Now,
this is this is what catapulted the
event of the 1798, the February of um um
10th and 15th event. Okay? The amount
soon increased. So he's telling us that
something there was a gathering
people started to show up and as the
citation I'm sorry the situation was
within the jurisdiction of the French
assemb ambassador the faction thought
themselves secure so they thought that
we're good it's going to happen to us
from at first only murmuring and
discontent to each other to to each
other then they proceeded to make public
herring I mean hair heranges I think it
says here
means a lengthy and aggressive speech
>> and showed clearly by several texts of
scripture that the time was at hand to
overthrow the existing government. So I
want you to understand what's taking
place is there's an occupation taking
place. They see it already happening.
They have the French you have Frenchmen
that are there. Nobody likes it when you
have a rival occupying your territory.
You follow what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> So there's an taking place and they now
people are disputing. They're arguing.
You know how people get. Okay. Now, I
want you to notice the one that's take
the the person that is the key person
that catapults what happens that locks
us into um prophetic history is this man
here, French General Nether Muran Dufa.
>> He was relative to Napoleon. He was
there. He was dispatched to go to Rome.
Okay. Now, check this out. While he's
there, what Dupo was just mentioning,
okay, here's an account of what's taking
place. You can tell by the picture
because it's not my picture. You can
find it online. Dufod is in the center.
He's holding his sword up. Okay, there's
people being shot. That's fine. Okay, so
check this out. This is his account. He
was an eyewitness to all the events that
were taking place. On page 12 and 13, he
goes on to say the following. In
consequence of the great noise and
confusion that necessarily took place,
Joseph Bonapart and his friends hastened
from their room to inquire into the
cause and came down to the midst of the
crowd and with their swords drawn,
though without any intention of
hostility, for General Dufot was seen
pointing his his to the ground. Oh, I
thought it was up. It was his hand and
then his sword to the ground. So, in
other words, he was I'm not there to
fight with you guys. I'm he's pointing
his sword at. So that was a signal of
just that. Whilst he was calling out to
the cavalry to speak with their
commanding officer, he goes on to say,
"But in the bustle and confusion of the
conflict, it was more than probable he
was not heard. You know, there's so much
commotion there. There's yelling,
there's shooting, everything or
understood by those whom he had
addressed himself during the promiscuous
firing that took place for the purpose
of dispersing the mob." What does it say
there and highlighted? This general was
unfortunately killed.
>> Okay. For what nation was he from again?
>> France.
>> From France. I said it was it was
France. Remember he was relative to
>> right
>> to Napoleon. Okay.
>> Napoleon. Okay.
>> So he was killed. I want you to notice
was taking place. An event which from
every information I have been able to
collect was the effect and chance of
chance and not by design.
>> Wow.
>> It just happened. Wow.
>> continues to write. Check this out.
Check this out. A few days before the
arrival of the French in Rome, Prince
Belmont
and then the then Neopolitan ministered
to the Holy Sea went by the request of
the Pope to meet the French army. So
what this is trying to say is as a
result of what took place and I'm going
to give you more evidence. As a result
of what took place, who was dispatched?
Who's the name that you see there on the
right bottom right right hand corner?
Uh, Louise
or Lewis Alexander Berier. Oh, Berthier.
Okay.
>> Berthier. So, he shows up now in the
sea. Okay. And I want you to notice the
then Neapolitan minister to the Holy Sea
went by the request of the Pope. So, in
other words, the Pope noticed that there
they land on the shores. The Pope
dispatches this man, Prince Bonte
to go and meet up with Alexander
Alexander Berier. It goes on to say to
meet with the French army in order to
learn from the commander in chief his
precise intention. He says go find out
why that brother is showing up on our on
on our shores. they got they started to
get bad
>> um paranoid
>> at the same time perhaps to remind him
of former promises which he had
previously received from the directory
when at Paris as this was the famed
noblemen who negotiated the peace for
the kings of no the king of Naples
listen to how um no Mikey please I hope
I are you following
>> I am
>> okay listen to what it says here birth
here told him to to Belmonte
I want you to read that read read the
following
>> that the only objective of the directory
was to apprehend the person accessess
the person's
accessory to the death of Duour Dufot
>> Du
>> Du fought with this guy was he killed
>> okay so what this is telling us that the
reason Why Bertha was dispatched to the
shores of Rome was for one reason, one
reason only. To apprehend those that had
nothing to do with the killing of this
kinsman to Napoleon. Did you get what I
just said?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, I want you to continue read.
Go ahead. Continue to read.
and that the pope might rest assured of
the utmost security that the same leg
legislative power had expressly
commanded him to respect the existing
government, the Catholic religion and
all public as well as private property
and that he would not even enter into
the city of Rome. The more satis
>> Okay. He was told, he was commanded, I
need you to show up and I need you to
find those people that had anything to
do with the killing of Dufot. And also
he got orders from the assembly that is
from the governing body back in France.
>> Mhm.
>> That he was to respect the what existing
government and what else?
>> The the pope
I'm lost. It
>> says respect Catholic religion. Yeah.
>> Stop there. Okay. So if he's sent there
to respect not only the government but
the Catholic religion, how is that than
atheism?
>> Yeah, really good point. Yeah.
>> What I'm reading through history is
given us quite the opposite. That's not
why they showed up on the
>> It had nothing to do with religion. It
was a political issue.
>> Wow.
>> It was a strictly political. It had
nothing to do with religion. But people
tend to believe 1798 it was France and
France was atheistical. So therefore,
atheism took out Pope took out
Christianity. No, Christianity was
already out the year before.
>> Wow, dude. This is completely new to me
cuz Yeah, I'd always heard it that way,
too.
>> Right. This is why we remember
>> she said in the beginning, I'm I got I
got I'm sorry. Just just bear with me
just a moment. She said in the beginning
>> of of this statement, remember and you I
had you read it. Read on the bottom the
last sentence where it says movements.
Read that.
>> Uh movements are at work to bring us to
the front. And if our theories of truth
can be picked to pieces by historians or
the world's greatest men, it will be
done.
>> Yeah.
>> You see why I'm doing this study?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> We better have our history in check. And
this is exactly why I will have you on
or have anyone else on because I would
have never seen this, you know, and how
are we going to just say, "Oh, no. He
doesn't believe what I believe, so I'm
not going to listen to him.
>> I'm just not that. That's not my
mentality, man.
>> Exactly. I just have a hope in mind. If
it's wrong, it's going to fall to
pieces, brother." Right.
>> And again, if you think that I'm wrong,
that's fine. I'm giving you the
evidence.
>> Yeah. you make a very
>> So let's go back to this statement. I
want you to continue to read read from
the top again.
>> All right. And that the pope might be
might rest assured of the utmost
security that the same legislative power
had expressly commanded him to respect
the existing government, the Catholic
religion, and all public as well as
private property and that he would not
even enter into the city of Rome. the
more satisfactory sat satisfactoriily
to assure his holiness of these
declarations. He com he committed them
to writing and gave them to the the
Neapolitan minister demanding at the
same time that the pope on his part
should issue an edict to tranquilize the
minds of the people. Whoa.
>> Continue to read. Continue to read. in
order to prevent any cause of bloodshed
and that nothing should be removed from
the museums, the libraries, the
galleries. Asserting that if these
conditions were not complied with in the
most unequivocilical manner, he had
orders to take possession of Rome and
the eccles the ecclesiastical state by
force.
>> You'll notice the terms. Listen, you
better do it this way or we are going to
>> that was the condition. That was the
reason why he came into Rome eventually.
But it's going to get better.
>> Finish reading this. Finish reading
this.
>> After his holiness received this
information, he sent some deputies to
enter into a more specific enga
engagement with Berier as to the terms
of accommodation, but they were refused
an audience. Wow.
>> So, in other words, he stated the terms
and and what Alexander just basically
did, he said when the people showed up
again, he said, "I already said what I
had to say. I'm done. I'm done." He
basically said, "I'm done talking."
>> Can you can you put some of this in
layman's terms? Cuz it's almost like
reading King James or something. This
Okay. So, so my understanding is that in
1798 it was the fault. It was like the
fatal head wound of Rome. We noticed
that the beast has a fatal head wound
and it'll come back to life. A lot of
people get that um misunderstood too.
They think it's going to be a literal
person's going to be shot in the head
and come back to life some. But the
kingdom, the beast kingdom suffered a
fatal head wound. It comes back to life.
That fatal head wound was 1798 when
General Berier pulled the what I've
always heard was he ripped the pope off
the throne and threw him in exile. But
this is
that's accurate, I guess. But it's it's
the um it's the motive.
>> Yes. Exactly. What was the pretext of
coming into Rome?
>> Because if this is this is written by
the guy, I mean, he he sounds like he
still has respect
>> for
>> his holiness and all this stuff, right?
>> But but let me tell you something. What
you're reading is what we're not talking
about that we need to be talking about.
Yeah.
>> The point of the matter is this is the
following. I'm giving you historical
data to the reason why the French did
show up on the shores of Rome. It wasn't
to decianize, if you will.
>> Yeah,
>> that wasn't the purpose. It was very
clear he's going to let everything stay
intact. But these are the terms for
something else that we're coming here
for. It had nothing to do with religion,
>> right? And what you just read here says
here that if these conditions were not
complied with in the most unequivocal
manner, he had orders from France to
take possession of Rome. In other words,
you're going to you're going to submit
to the terms and if you don't, we're
coming in by force,
>> right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, it isn't done yet. Oh, we're
going to establish this point. It's
going to be concrete.
>> Amen.
>> After his holiness received his
information, he sent it some. you just
read this to enter into a more specific
engagement. In other words, no, no, we
get to we need to he needs to um he
needs to fine-tune this this this point
that he's trying to make.
>> Yeah.
>> This the pope this past more of this
messengers. They came back and said this
brother ain't talking. He already told
us what he said and that he means it.
>> Well, guess what? The Pope did not
comply. What did I just say?
>> The Pope did not comply. Wow.
>> Check this out. So eventually he does
come in
>> and this is what took place. On the 10th
of February, the castle of St. Angelo
was summoned to surrender and the pope's
troops had four had four hours given
them to evacuate. In this evacuation,
the convicts were set at liberty, each
being permitted to go where he pleased
and knock off his irons at his own
convenience. The gates of the city were
immediately taken possession. I want you
to know, brother. It's going to get
better. Check this out. The gates of the
city were immediately taken possession
of. And the pope, the cardinals, three
only accepted with the whole people of
Rome were made what?
>> Prisoners
>> at the discretion of the Republican
army. That's the French. Okay. Now,
check this out.
>> I want you to notice now. Please don't
miss it. If there's anything you need to
notice in is this.
>> Okay. what he says in the book on page
3637. The first proclamation
made by the general and chief was to
ensure all the people of the ecclesi
ecclesiastical state. When we say
ecclesiastical, we're talking about the
church. Okay?
>> Right?
>> That they might rely with confidence on
the French army for protection. Check
this out. Finish reading it. Finish.
I'll let you read it. as well in their
property as in their persons and that
the Catholic religion should be most
inviably respected. Oo,
>> that doesn't sound like atheistical,
does it?
>> No, not at all.
>> Because if I unders, correct me if I'm
wrong, back in France when the French
assembly got together to house religion,
they weren't talking like this. They
weren't going to respect anybody's
religion, right?
>> Not at all. That's not what happened in
1798 because um rel rather the ousting
of the two scriptures
>> was done away with by 1797 by law that
is
>> wow
>> even though it was already being
permeated within France but by law we
are told three and a half years exactly
to the day
>> they brought back religion into society
because they knew they cannot live
without it. So in 1798 it wasn't she
never says Ellen G. White never says
atheism took out France I mean took out
Pope. What she says is
>> France took out the papacy. That's all
she says.
>> Right
>> now we're understanding the reasons the
motives behind it.
>> Now that's what we wrote. I'm going to
now read to you the actual proclamation
sent by and signed by Alexander Berier.
You don't get this in some of our
churches.
>> You don't get this. When did you ever
hear? Check this out. Now, this is the
actualation.
>> Now, this is going to be clear. Listen
to what Berthier just said. This is him
writing. This is Berthier himself
writing this. All the inhabitants of the
ecclesiastical state may be assured that
their persons, their property, their
churches, and religion shall be what?
>> Protected by the French army. Wow.
>> Does that sound like atheistical to you?
>> Not at all. Whoa.
>> Okay. Check this out. The functions of
the church shall be what? Religiously
respected.
>> Wow.
>> Therefore, all public demonstrations and
devotion ought to continue without any
change or alteration signed by him.
>> Wow.
>> You can't get any clearer than that.
>> That's correct.
>> Not my words. That's Alexander Beriars.
And then I'll finally this headquarters
from Rome. He's writing from Rome the
22nd. Remember the sixth year of the
French Republic. remember that was still
going on with that in that calendar, but
it was going to soon change as well too.
>> Mhm.
>> Because it was could just implement it
just all of a sudden because they they
eradicated everything, but they're
trying to bring everything back.
>> But again, it's being clear it was not
done for religious purposes,
>> right?
>> Signed in 1798.
Now, in Wikipedia.org,
this is what it has to say. Remember
General Dufot,
>> the K to um to um Napoleon, it has this
to say. bone apart then put Dufot going
back I'm going back to that story it
says here of organizing the troops of
the uh siline
I don't know how to say it forgive me
republicine
I'm sorry I think that's how you
pronounce it he rose to general de
brigade in the army de Ital it Italic on
the 30th of March 1797 he then went to
Rome with the French ambassador Jonapart
Bonapart where they both tried to ins
cite a Republican revolt. I want you to
notice what Wikipedia is saying,
>> especially by hosting a Republican
festival at Joseph's Palace. This caused
a riot and Dufont was what?
>> I'm sorry, I got lost where you're at.
Du font was oh, fatally shot
>> in what year?
>> December 1797.
>> Truth. Now listen to the next sentence.
His death gave Bonapart what does it say
here? the pretext he needed to occupy
Rome.
>> That's the reason why history is telling
you that's the reason why they went into
Rome. It wasn't for any religious
reasons. It wasn't to house religion
that has nothing because religion was
back in the society a year before,
>> right?
>> Abolish the papal state and to set up a
Roman Republic. It doesn't stop there.
In the book called the Oxford history of
the French Revolution, okay, it says
this, the riot in Rome on December on
December 28th, 1797 accidentally led to
the death of the French general. So it
wasn't really premeditated. It wasn't
that it was used as a pretext for
invading the papal states. That was the
reason why they went in. And on the 15th
of February, a drooper jackab proclaimed
the Roman Republic and were at once
recognized the pope. What does it say
here?
>> The prisoner.
>> That same Pas 6, he was taken what?
>> Wow. Taken prisoner.
>> Okay, that was in 1798. Remember that.
Now,
>> what was the real reason why the Pope
was removed from office? You don't want
to miss this.
>> Check this out. It's going to tell you.
Now, going back to that book from um
Dupa, Richard Dupa, listen to what he
says, and I'm quoting.
After the French had taken possession of
Rome and before they had formally
analled their his authority, they
requested that his treasurer and they'll
give the name de laora should publish an
edict to ascertain and listen to what it
says here. Confiscate all the property
>> of those foreigners. This is not the
local um local um regions or lands.
These are foreign um places, okay?
whose nations were at war with the
republic meaning French as English,
Portuguese and Russians. Let let's so
for layman's terms reason layman re for
layman's reasons behind it I'm going to
explain.
So basically Rome had in their
jurisdiction a compact with other
nations. It gave you a list of them. The
English, the Portuguese and and
Russians.
Mhm.
>> France wants to confiscate those titles,
if you will, by force.
>> Yeah.
>> Listen to this. This the Pope most posit
positively what?
>> Uh refused
>> declaring that he would not break his
faith with his friends by giving his
ascent to so unwarrantable a measure. So
he's saying Berthier shows up and says,
"Listen, we want you to give us those
titles if you will." And what does the
pope say? No, we ain't going to do that.
I'm not going to break my leg the
people. And you know what Berier said?
Oh yeah. Okay. Check this out.
>> At the Colantino in 1797, Pope Pas was
compelled to surrender Avagon Avicia.
They're talking about their own church.
What happened in this year,
>> right?
>> It's prophetic. It's it's a proven fact.
But they're giving us details of what
took place. Era Balona and R M R Ro
Romanga and to pay 15 million Franks and
give up numerous costly works of art and
manuscripts in an attempt to
revolutionize Rome. The French general
Dola Dufa was shot and killed. Here you
have it again.
>> Where the French took Rome on February
10th, 17 what?
>> 98
>> and proclaimed the Roman what? Republic.
>> You know what it means by republic? If
it was a monarchy, it's because the pope
was the head, right? They removed the
pope as a king.
>> Now it gives makes it a republic. In
other words, make gives it and grants
the people the rights to now lead that
nation. That's why we're a republic,
right?
>> It's the people that decide.
>> Okay? Because the pope refused to what
now?
>> To submit.
He was forcibly taken from Rome on the
night of the 20th of February and
brought first to Sienna and then to
Florence. I want you to notice what
history is telling us the reason why he
submitted to those terms is the why he
it was the reason why he they ousted
him.
>> No other reason.
>> Wow.
>> Wasn't because he was it was a religious
entity.
>> Show me. Remember
>> if our theories of truth can be picked
to pieces by the greatest historians
>> it will
>> it will be done. There goes your proof.
Now, how can this be picked to pieces
now?
>> Because it's there.
>> Interesting. One day, one day, now this
is going to tie into Revelation chapter
13 about the the wounding, the wound,
the deadly wound that you just mentioned
earlier. I just walked out of a book. I
just glanced and I saw this book at a
discounted table. I took I said, "Oh,
the papacy." Since, you know, I like to
read history about the papacy. I said,
"Let me take it." Nobody referred this
book. I just took it off the shelf. One
day, I opened the book and this is what
it said. I was just looking through it
and this my eyes fell upon this um
quotation.
In 1796, Bonapart marched toward the
city and at the piece of toolino the
pope seated to the French the leg
leation sorry of Bologona Ferrer and
Raana as well as a Avagnan. This is what
we just read from from the Catholic
encyclopedia here. This is what we just
read. But this is different book. It has
nothing to do in relation to one
another. Okay, this is what they're
saying. and paid the identity
of 30 million liveries. Joseph Bonapart,
this was Napoleon's older brother.
Didn't I say he was king?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Became French ambassador.
But the death But I'm sorry. But the
death in a riot of the French general of
Dufot. I'm sorry. I didn't mean that. I
didn't mean that. I didn't. Joseph
Boneart was the oldest brother. I'm
sorry. I mixed the two. I I I got the
two confused on this end. But the French
general Dufat, I said he was kin. I was
meaning Joseph Bonapart. Forgive me for
that mate. I just made it clear before
we even ended it. Thank God I did. I
caught it.
>> Thank you, Lord. You know how people
like to rip things away.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Friends wrote, "Was the pretext for the
occupation of Rome in what year?"
>> 1798.
>> By what general?
>> The general birth year. Wow.
>> Check this out. Who set up a Roman
Republic which lasted until what year?
>> when the French were expelled from
Italy. Now I check this out. This comes
from the book the papacy. Not my words,
their words. Check check check. You're
going to see what they're going to say.
The French plundered the treasures of
the city and abducted the alien
octogenarian
which means to say in his 80s he was in
his 80s. Pope Pas I 6 to Sienna then to
Florence, Parma and Balance where he
died as Jeang
Brashki exercising the p the profession
of Pontis. Now listen to the la read the
last words.
>> It looked like the end of the papacy.
>> Oh wow.
>> And I saw one of wounded to death.
>> Wow. Revelation.
>> Isn't that interesting? Mhm.
>> 179 have a we have a um a yearly anchor
point.
>> Okay. Even the papacy themsel or
historian that's writing about the
papacy says it looked like they were
done with away with it was over
>> with that institution.
>> The Bible predicted it and they're not
even using the Bible to quote that.
That's not what they're getting it from.
>> It disappeared that it was done because
they ousted the king, if you will, of
that empire. In other words, again,
church and state was
>> analled.
>> Okay? And then the Bible says here,
remember, go ahead, read this. He that
leadth into captivity shall go into
captivity. He that kleth with the sword
must be killed with the sword. Here is
the patience of the Here is the patience
and faith of the saints.
>> So, did we establish yourself that it
couldn't have been atheism in 1798 that
took out the papacy?
>> Absolutely.
>> Okay. So, let's go back to Daniel 11.
We're about to close right now. So,
let's go back to Daniel chapter 11 in um
um Oh, I have it here. Let me correct
this out. Oh, I know what I did. I put I
copied this this what you call Okay,
1140. Here we go. All right. There we
go.
All right. So,
at the time of the end, are we now going
to continue to say that it was atheism?
>> We shouldn't. we should that's not the
truth uh based on history.
>> So now we just eliminated
that concept that it was atheism that
was that's considered the um the king of
the south because if you want to
continue to say you can go ahead and
continue to state that but where's your
evidence that it was atheism
>> took out from um um France I mean that
took out pope.
>> I'm not here suggesting that it wasn't
France. No, it was the nation that was
used, but it wasn't an atheistical
nation at the time.
>> Right.
>> So therefore, we go back to what it
really that what it might be. What I'm
suggesting it was it was Islam.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, it's very I'm going to close with
this powerful words. Check this out.
Now, remember the ruling factor I the
ruling um um leader of um France was
who? Who do you see on your screen?
>> Napoleon Bonapart.
Listen to this. Couple years later,
remember France was atheistic, right?
>> A lot of people don't really read.
>> I didn't read before, but I wanted to
learn. That's how I only That's how I
learned reading, right? Yes or no?
>> Yeah.
>> Check this out. In 19 sorry, 17 what
year?
>> 1797.
>> Remember, a year before
1798,
Napoleon said to the Milan Parish
priest, I want you to read it. Society
without religion is like a ship without
a compass. Whoa.
>> Does that sound like atheistical to you?
>> Not at all. I didn't know he said that.
>> I know a lot of people did. I didn't
either until I studied this out. I said,
"Oh my good, this is here. It's out
there."
>> Wow.
>> And it's interesting. Eventually, years
later, during his captivity, Napoleon
complained to the monolan
of having no chaplain. He That's
interesting. He wanted a chaplain. He
was in captivity.
a lot of sense with somebody that's
atheistical, right?
>> Pope seventh, now this is the new pope
that came into the power later on
petition England to grant Napoleon's
wish. That's interesting. You need the
one
>> that is so you oust it. That's
interesting. Wow. He comes to Napoleon's
wish and Abra Vnali became his chaplain.
Check this out. Right.
Napoleon affirmed to mon his belief in
God and read out loud the Old Testament.
This is this is Napoleon. He reads out
loud the Old Testament out loud. The
Gospels and the Acts of the Apostles.
Napoleon stated, I want you to read it.
>> The Bible is no mere book, but a living
creature with a power that conquers all
that oppose it.
That's amazing. I was literally about to
look up that quote because this is the
only quote I know by Napoleon and I
learned it years ago from a guy named
Chuck Mistler. And um in my mind I was
sitting here thinking like I need to
look this up because it was just a
random quote for me. I had no reason to
even know it, but I thought it fit
perfectly perfectly with this. And um
you have it. That's amazing,
>> brother. I never even read this quote
before and so I started reading and
looking you get it. I said okay if some
people are saying this now I want you to
understand that the term atheism is not
an estam established view in concrete in
in even in my church is people have some
people have this opinion that it's that
and that's fine everybody's entitled to
it. I was also a believer in that until
I started to look into it. Why? Because
if you're going to hand me something, I
want to believe it, but I got to find
the evidence because as a, you know, as
I teach and as I preach, I got to make
sure I have my ducks in a row.
>> Amen.
>> I don't want to prove it later on. You
get what I'm saying? I don't want to.
>> Okay. Now, I'm reading this and this is
what history is telling me. So, remember
a a dictator stating such words like
this.
>> Now, let's close with these close with
two statements from two writers. One of
which that I believe is very inspired
and one I'm going to close with a
powerful preacher of the 1800s. Check
this out.
>> Going back to that book, The Great
Controversy, she goes, she says this.
Since France made war upon God's two
witnesses, they have been honored as
what? Never before. Wow. Goes on to
history. In 1804, the British and
Foreign Bible Society was organized.
This was followed by similar
organizations with numerous branches
upon the continent of Europe. In 1816,
the American Bible Society was founded.
>> When the British Society was formed, the
Bible had been printed and circulated in
50 tongues. Now, check this out. It has
since been translated into many hundreds
of languages and dialects. She goes on
to say, check this out. The infidel
Voltater, now everybody's heard of Vol.
Remember, he was the atheist of the
time. once boast boastingly said, "I am
weary of hearing people repeat that 12
men established the Christian religion."
Listen to what this this man had the
boldness to say something like this. I
will prove that one man may suffice to
overthrow it. He's talking about
himself.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. You got 12 people that brought in
religion.
>> I'mma prove that one man oust it.
>> Wow.
>> Generations have passed since his death.
Millions have joined the war upon the
Bible. It means another attempts have
been happening. Even in America, they
try to do it. But it is so far from
being destroyed that where there were a
hundred in Voltater's time, there are
now 10,000 yes 100,000 copies of the
book of God. Now people want to say,
"Well, America's becoming Yes. But let
me tell you something. Listen,
>> atheism is going has permeated all
throughout the globe. It didn't start at
the time. We already read it. Even
Pharaoh was an atheist." Yeah.
>> So it's always been sitting there.
>> So nobody's saying that it's completely
gone away. Not even from Francis. French
society. That's not what we're saying.
What we're saying is prophet said that
the the legislative assembly, the
national convention was going to out it
by law in three and a half years it was
only going to be given. By three and a
half years later, we got to bring it
back. And they made it into law again.
So how in the world if it's in 1797 and
1798, the year later, France is still
atheistical and that's the reason why
they they invaded um Rome. That's not
what history tells us.
>> If history doesn't say you want to
continue on, do away with it. Go ahead.
If you want to get yourself in a rut
later on to try to explain that away,
go. It's fine with me.
>> But I need my evidence to prove it.
>> Amen.
>> And then she lastly says this. In the
words of an early reformer concerning
the Christian church, the bi I love
this. Read this. Read read that
highlighted section. Read it.
>> The the Bible is an anvil that has worn
out many hammers. Whoa. That's good.
>> Isn't that interesting?
>> Yeah. Say the Lord, no weapon that is
formed against thee shall prosper, and
every tongue that shall rise against
thee in judgment, thou shalt condemn.
Isaiah 54:17. The word of our God shall
stand for how long, Mikey?
>> Forever.
>> I say, praise be to Jesus. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen, brother.
>> And then I lastly, I will close it out
with this famous preacher of the 1800s.
I love this. He was a Baptist preacher.
Check this out. You ever heard of
Charles H. Spurgeon?
>> I have. He's one of them. And matter of
fact, he spoke heavily against the
Catholic Church. Now remember, we're not
talking about the people. We're talking
about the system,
>> okay?
>> We love Catholics. That's Let's be very
clear.
>> This is not against Catholic. We love
Catholics. We love any pro. We don't We
even love Muslims.
>> Amen.
>> We don't like some They do.
>> Yeah.
>> But we love them. Now, listen to what he
said. I'm now quote, "The Bible is God's
Bible. And when I see it, I seem to hear
a voice springing up from it, saying, "I
am the book of God." Wow,
>> man. Read me. I am God's writing. Open
my leaf, for I was pinned by God. Read
it. He says, for he is my author, and
you will see him visible and manifest
everywhere. Would you say amen to that
one?
>> Amen. That's amazing.
>> Those are powerful words, man. They are.
>> And with thus saying that, I conclude
today's subject. This is the end,
>> man. Good job, bro. Like, you know, as I
said the first time you came on, I never
really dove into the topic of the king
of the north, king of the south. I
always heard it thrown around like, "Oh,
who is he?" And and I heard different
things. I've I've often heard uh
atheism. I've heard um Turkey, Roman
Empire, but what you brought the first
time was a lot of great evidence that
proved to me according to the Bible,
history, geography, that the king of the
north is papal Rome, the king of the
south is Islam. And we got a lot of back
and forth. We got a lot of um it was a
controversial topic. There was people in
the comments that said, "No, that's not
true. It's it's the king of the north is
Turkey. The king of the south is
atheism." They even referenced Walter
Vice, who I love, Walter Vith. But
again, I'm not going to put my faith and
trust in any man. I don't care who it
is. I got to see the evidence myself.
And I there's there's a people out there
I I get a lot of great information from
people like Kent Hovind and Chuck
Mistler and all these people and they
don't I don't I disagree with a lot of
stuff that they believe as well because
of the evidence that I found. What you
did tonight
was showed the people who are in
opposition which are mostly 7th day
Adventist from their own writings from
history that this is not historically
accurate that French was atheistic and
therefore it cannot be atheism. The king
of the south cannot be atheism and uh
seems to point to Islam. I'm with you
man. Um, I've been seeing a a lot of
comments in here from people saying,
"Reach out to your church. Invite
Earnest to come share this because the
time is near." And I believe that, man.
So, if somebody wanted you to come to
their church, how could they reach you?
And would you present this at their
church? Sure. What you can do, you can
call me or text me. My number is
58-271-8660.
Again, that's 58-271-8660.
Mikey, I think that you will have it
also on the comment section and you will
you will note it there. Is that correct?
>> I will put it in the description. It's
on the description of the first video as
well.
>> Okay. And then put also the website that
they can contact me through is that is
marytillupart.com.
Um they will send you to that link to
the is a marriage seminar website that I
have. I have another one. I'm getting
ready to launch another website that
will deal more with the evangelism side
if you will like something like this.
But for right now, you can use that to
contact me. It's married. M A R R I E D
O one word till t I l you the letter U.
Okay. Part P A R T.
Married to part all one word.com.
And you can contact me through that.
and if you need to u message me or ask
me to speak or whatever the case may be.
>> Yep. The uh his contact will be in the
description here. If for some reason you
can't find it and you guys know how to
reach out to me, I'll give it to you
because I want I want you to spread this
stuff, man, because I love the truth.
And to me, this this like the like the
thumbnail says, this dispels all the
misunderstandings about prophecy. And I
think it's important. And uh you're a
man of many hats, many talents. You also
do marriage seminars and you do
counseling or just marriage seminars and
>> I do that and sometimes people don't
understand when you got to when Listen,
every marriage is not perfect, right?
>> Amen. None of them are.
>> Well, Aubrey too, right? If she ain't
perfect, you ain't perfect.
>> Exactly.
>> That's exactly right.
>> You get what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. We got to be told. You know what
I'm saying? You got a sticky feet,
right? Hey, I'm every marriage, listen,
the best time, you know what I I have
found in counseling sometimes the best
reason or best reason or rather rather
let me rephrase it. One of the best
tools that you can ever use as
counseling is your own experience.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> Brother, don't do that. Or sister, don't
do that. Listen, I've been through that.
I'm going through that. Don't do that.
Not leading us anywhere.
>> God is saying we shouldn't be doing it.
In other words, your own experience
would testify, listen and help them to
understand, listen, listen to the
brother because the brother's either
going through it or went through it.
>> Amen.
>> Follow what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> And remember, all sinners needing grace.
>> Amen.
>> Okay. And God didn't pick pick perfect
people in order to to give messages
because if he did, I'm sure not worthy
of it. Neither are you. Right.
>> That's right. 100%.
>> Well, brother, thank you so much for
bringing this to us. It was over three
hours, but man, there has been on
average a steady 130 people in here. We
still got 100 people in here, over 125
thumbs up. So, people are loving it. And
I'm I'm just so thankful that people are
choosing to use their time to dig in
God's word, man. This is this is, you
know, people always ask, "What am I
supposed to do if I can't watch movies
and play video games?" And this get in
God's word, man. Dig for truth. like
gold. We're in the last days. Deception
is on the rise. Jesus is coming soon. I
want to be ready. The only way we can be
ready and not be deceived is to
understand God's word, prophetic events,
and to live according to his word,
follow his commandments, and be ready
for when he returns. So, thank you so
much,
>> and that's the whole point of this
series that I'm doing. And remember, I I
really I really I I can teach about many
other things. Believe me, I don't need
to get into something that's going to
just going to draw more controversy,
especially towards me. But you know
what? We're living in the last days.
Just get with it. It's going to draw, no
matter what you do, you want to
controversy.
>> But the question is, do you want to
stand for truth?
>> Amen.
>> And where do you stand?
>> I want to stand where there is truth.
>> Not my truth, not your truth, but the
Bible truth.
>> Amen.
>> And this Yeah. Comment is saying the
comment and person saying better than
video games. Hey, it is so better than
video games.
>> Amen.
better than video games. And the thing
is, brother, this is the reason why I'm
doing this. See, I know this is long and
drawn out. I get it. I get it. But you
see the nec the necessity behind it.
>> Yeah. How many times do we just waste
three hours, man, on nonsense?
>> Yeah.
>> Going out to do, you waste it.
>> Some of us,
>> the Titanic, we'll sit down and watch it
from beginning to end. I don't even get
up to use the bathroom.
>> Yep. But then complain. But then we want
to complain when we got to sit down to
hear this and then oh we got to listen.
Well, guess what? You don't get this
information now. Soon you're not going
to be able to.
>> That's so true, man.
>> Remember, buy no buy no sale. You won't
even be able to go to YouTube. Oh, I'll
learn it today. How you going to do it?
You can't pay that bill.
>> Yeah.
>> Not if you're on the go side.
>> Listen, I Yeah, I listen. When I was in
the streets, um Mikey, you already heard
this. When I was in the streets before,
I gave my life to the enemy. M
>> anything he wanted me I was devoted into
doing it. I would put hours and upon
hours to do what he's asked me to do.
But guess what? The ball has changed. I
mean the game has changed.
>> Amen.
>> God says when you put that much effort
to my cause now you better believe it I
would do it. I don't get everything
right. I don't get everything right. But
by God's grace he gets me back on track.
>> Amen. Amen. Brother.
>> You know what I'm saying?
>> One day I got to have you on to share
your testimony.
>> Oh that you sure you want to do that?
>> Yeah man. I don't even know if I've
heard all the details.
>> No, it ain't as bad as maybe people may
people think. No, I was I was still a
good boy in the streets, believe it or
not. I didn't do all right.
>> Yeah,
>> but I'm not I'm not those mass murderer
or anything like that. But anyways, but
yeah, we could do that. Let's get these
messages out first. We remember we're
going to have to get back with dealing
with the 70we prophecy.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> We want to deal with that. That's very
important, very crucial. Okay. And for
those that are listening, our next
series now, this was we kind of
digressed a bit from the main point of
the kingdom of the north, king of the
south, because I needed to tackle this
issue. Yeah.
>> But you notice what I did um today, what
the Lord did.
>> He tackled another prophecy that we now
fully understand what it really is.
>> Amen.
>> For those that not even non-sethday
Adventist, as you said, now they got the
an understanding of what Revelation 11
is talking or is referring to as versus
what it's not. Well, you've presented
what you believe is to be the truth and
then you're today you've taught people
how to defend the rebuttals because this
is going to be the rebuttal that comes
up and people are going to be like,
"Well, I actually heard it was Turkey
and atheism." And it's like if you don't
know how to defend that, you're just
going to be like, "Well, I don't know
which it is." You know?
>> Correct. Correct. So, again, you know,
again, everybody still got to do their
homework. Don't take my work as your
>> go. Yeah.
>> Don't take it. Yeah. and may have sound
convincing, but that doesn't make any
doesn't mean a hill of beans when it
comes to you and standing for what is
right.
>> Amen.
>> You need to do your own work. So the
same resource, listen, you got Amazon,
you got a lot of places that you can buy
all this material. You don't have to get
it from me. Get it secondhand. Go to go
to eBay. Go get it now because real soon
we're not going to be able to get it.
>> So true.
>> Amen.
>> So, you know, let's just think about
that. Let's just move forward with that
thought in mind.
>> Amen. Well, bro, thank you so much for
your time, for your wisdom on this, and
I I see that a lot of people are blessed
by it, and I'm looking forward to having
you back on next time.
>> We'll get we'll get together for Yes,
that's another point. We're going to get
we're going to resume back on the topic
of the kingdom of the north, king of
South, but we're going to deal more
primarily with the latter portion,
>> okay,
>> of of that is from verses 40 to 45 and
then of course dealing with Revelation
12. I mean, I'm sorry. Daniel 12:es 1-4.
Okay. Or 1-7, really.
>> Awesome.
>> So, we'll get back with you. It'll be in
the next couple days, though. Okay.
>> Sounds good. Thank you. If you guys
Yeah, let's do that.
>> Right.
>> Lord, Father in heaven, we just thank
you so much for wisdom that you grant
us, Lord. There's nothing that we know
of our own. And I just thank you for um
just filling us with your Holy Spirit,
giving us eyes of discernment and just
guiding us and leading us into all
truth, Lord. And Lord, we just ask that
you would continue to do that. Continue
to give us eyes to see and ears to hear.
Continue to give us um hearts that yearn
for truth and that will dig, that we'll
spend time seeking your truth instead of
just wasting it, Lord. And forgive us
for wasting so much of our time when
life is short. And I just pray that the
words spoken here tonight will reach
someone who has been asking for these
exact answers and that they will see
this, that they will feel like it was a
a a good direction and they will seek it
out and test it to see if it's true.
Lord, we love you. We thank you for all
that you do and ask that you just
continue to bless us and continue to
guide and direct us and continue to make
us more like you every day in Jesus
name. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, my brother.
Listen. Say hello to your beloved wife.
May you keep your eyes fixed on Jesus.
Until we meet again on this platform,
>> let's just keep on looking up.
>> Amen.
>> That's where we're going.
>> Thank you, brother. Talk to you soon.
>> Take care. Blessings. Blessing to
everybody on your channel, too.
>> Amen. Thank you guys so much for being
here tonight. If you were blessed by
this, please give it a thumbs up. really
helps get this video out into the
algorithm so that more people can hear
this study and you know it could be a
great topic to discuss with family
members and friends. If you're new to
this channel, click subscribe so you
don't miss another video. We put out
videos once or twice a week. And if you
would like to support this ministry, you
can do so by going to candidtruth.org.
We got Cash App, Vinmozel, PayPal,
Patreon. We are 100% donor-based and you
can even invite us to come speak at your
church, school, event. We had a really
busy last year and our calendar is
filling up fast. So go to cantruth.org
and you can click on the booking tab. If
you like t-shirts, we got t-shirts,
hoodies, mugs, all kinds of merch that
have some cool sayings on them. And we
get about $5 for every sale on that. It
really helps this ministry continue. We
cannot do it without you. Everything we
do here, we're fulltime. And like I
said, we're donor based. So reach out to
us. Invite us to your church. Send a
donation if God is leading you to do
that or just click like, share it, and
that helps as well. We love you, we
thank you, and we'll see you guys next
time on Can of Truth.